[Music]
welcome podcast alright and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 82 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord who is not
only regarded as assistant to the
roundtable but it's always a pleasure to
see her at each and every III and
Microsoft function this lady is the
epitome of a true gamer with a passion
extremes insightful commentary and
impactful contributions for female
diversity and gamers of color
introducing a member of both the grown
women gaming and nerditude movements the
United States Navy protective ring and
our dedicated ILP stream team sister
making her debut into the realm of the
Lord my girl Lady l-boogie
how you doing sis I'm waiting for the
crowd Saturday when you playing at
absolute pleasure to have you in a room
you are a lady Lord at what you do it's
only right we have you here and show you
proper respect at the round table are
you ready to have some fun of course you
know we got the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords of the realm here
at the round table with our special
patreon tier introductions courtesy of
our deaf theatre
we working you know he's got the dates
up order so Marco Holmes with the call
most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and also
this Lord has collected every amiibo
released and is the biggest advocate for
Nintendo online you have ever seen epic
Bowser collection mommy
Lord he knows about my amiibos you be
talking about my Nemo's I told you
that's like confidential yeah assassin's
creed or say about that cool door phone
destiny or just take a little break
plain of things to be honest with you
once I beat the rave but I kind of
dropped destiny frame you can break now
you you've been doing extra hard no
doubt we should go so I know that's
that's good so now its origins which I'm
surprised you liking like you're really
liking it
I mean honestly excuse me not gorgeous
well I wasn't a big fan of origins
because I think mainly it was just I I
couldn't really justify the changing
gameplay because I was a huge fan of the
original ones so when they changed it it
was like a barrier I couldn't break you
know clearly they're not going back so
it's neither dropped the whole franchise
as a whole or just stop bitching and
play this I feel like
and of course we have I both Seneca
Gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the Sagittarius
mr. offline profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank also leader of
the switch hate movement it is the
president of third party games remaining
360p on the Nintendo Wii don't know
hacking our private accounts he's on
your Twitter it's really you're part of
living a double life man you need to
stop it he's got out of Boston with a
double yeah yeah been playing most how
to say man Lara Croft got thrown into
bushes and I'm get I'll get back to you
but that which has been in the bushes -
no I've been so amped to like I haven't
been working as many hours of past
couple weeks so I've been so amped to
get home and play my console so there's
more than this assassins that honestly
like I'm on lunch break I'm not really
even playing I'm not with somebody
and intend to need that upgrade already
[Laughter]
city [ __ ] is up and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS
gamer the Lord of combat sports was a
man of his convictions
the man is nothing less than that
premium experience and is the leader of
the fraud alert movement oh also Lord of
the who did that for you movement leader
of the PS class playstation classic and
brony movement and a spokesman of why
the Nintendo switch is the greatest
console ever beloved don't let anybody
know about that ran his mouth I was
supposed to be letting that go all
combat talk this afternoon this is what
I get you can't be telling our secrets
away like no one knows that but he was
at e3 he gave that extra extra dream
they even got all the anything you've
been playing this week it's been a very
crazy week because from jumping in
between getting my characters up to 600
and destiny to get my spider-man time in
oh hey you say anything about my
spider-man time at it man was good
everything I don't hear you say nothing
but my little cheese my doula
worthy of playing on the fourth which
looks like that's the game pass Oh
brothers so people lives are over
I was playing traveler telling ya and
then it was like one more of the games I
was trying to squeeze in there but these
days every time I get on that I get
messages man and then oh oh shout out to
you for oh oh you went to you can't find
that you wasn't on IOP anymore right
[Laughter]
oh you didn't want to do it right I
chose who got got future members current
was to stay active obviously we know
about that but yeah we do want to
promote is right for says that we do
want to promote people engaging with
each other like so if there's someone on
our cran wants to you know please reach
out also like I said King tag myself all
the guys that you see at home because at
the end of the day we don't want it to
be a situation where it was now it's
like everybody's kind of in their own
pocket with they own little two or three
people you know anything when I see a
Klan member L of Jian and somebody for
an eyeful and we have three pages of
people you don't need to beat it the
chance he said I play at his Early's
left me she said I hope I'm still long
or she says she's good now you use on
the fence but you you family though
let's go next one at the reaping it
caught bad bullets but no reason you
know say also all not bootytime I'm a
tipsy Laura tipsy using
but of course we have the game niche
himself no kognito also leader of the
Nintendo level is game of degeneration
Club supporter of amiibos for Happy
Meals movement and life of black tiger
is the very best game or ps4 whence your
therapist or something like that listens
to the show he was very meticulous with
these intros he told me exactly what he
wanted for every Lord shout out there
like I said no this is open to all the
Lord or one of our patreon ideas if you
want to do silly intro for us long as
it's respectful you know say we love
down for looking fun so yeah for me
obviously has been our destiny to have
been a lot of crucible as lady L buddy
knows
of a really grind I'm trying to get that
rhetorics really trying to get that
mouth feyza i don't get the meatball the
boss don't ever come out I don't have
three people to go into what I won't
even touch it I'm nice again poor I'm
nice like it's not is if you go on the
friend of people and even play a semi
confident team the moment their problem
evil pops up they're gonna go minutes to
see but here's the thing like as the
warlock with the well what I do is I'll
place it in the back of the mat first of
all I got I used to sleep at account of
people invading I put the leg in the
back of the back and I got the loot of
faction boom so if you jumping into my
bubble you're gonna get protected you're
gonna get melted by the prob you and all
the little little blockers and you do it
XD it's like my home I play nothing but
soul okay
I haven't play games with anyway I've
been literally winning like my rank is
crazy
but it's just that class for whatever
reason is really good for that support
well even if they semi-competent they
real oh hey he got a bubble oh he got
the lunar faction he just keep reloading
so that kind of thing was been going on
for me with that is not my dearly I'm
not going I used to play it all the time
you know about other people but once you
do it once and you're just like wow like
I've had I've literally had it - more
weed summon the primeval first and base
some when there's like three minutes
later and they melted him so fast well
no I know the hustle is just I'm not
communicating with the other three
people to the hospital
I'll cut me a cut you oh I was saying
that I I have the same problem like you
know and people act like they don't know
what they're doing like people getting
15 motes still trying but what are you
doing as soon as you have 15 take your
ass to
well exactly people do it too much I
agree with King I feel like their bounty
should be restructured to a point
because I feel like it's kind of like
completely defeating the purpose of
having teamwork when you're asking
people to use guns they don't normally
play it you play with don't even do so
now you probably the first couple days
of every week it's like literally
they're gonna be playing with stuff you
know for a fact they don't care about
it's a bad experience for me it's a bad
experience for the people playing like
oh dude so yeah it's been like I said
really I was so mad I still haven't got
a chance to really touch for always a
force horizon because the day I was
ready to play
I'm stupidly did the doubt back with
download from the app but when I came
home I thought it was already installed
and that thing is like what 60 gigs or
whatever yeah so I was like damn and
then I got back on destiny and also
obviously this is the police too so you
know that's been going on so are we
gonna do a little brief arm I'm gonna
have to spare you nobody that we have to
do a brief you ever seen this okay I got
a woman he's been requested and just get
it - I want to start off real quick home
solve did you see before we get into the
main car which is what everybody here
for but did you see the other fights on
the other console no I missed all the
undercard cos I was out with the Lord
though that would look bad to Lord
Marlyn is I took I took one for the team
yeah
[Laughter]
you would you please well a free will
you please it wasn't like I don't think
it deserves that 33 rotten tomatoes like
I thought it was it was a serviceable
movie I mean we've seen followers like
fantastic for green lantern considerably
worse movies this movie it was slow but
once it got to the venom stuff it was
cool and I thought Tom Hardy was a good
Eddie Brock and a good venom I thought
his voice would annoy me it was a little
weird but I mean the dynamic between him
and the symbiote was but I thought it
was a it was fine I think to be honest
with you from like what I've seen I
think the fact that you know it's based
off spider-man and they're coming off
the spider-man hype and there's not
spider-man in it that's it might hurt
the movie overall but so the answer is
no all right all I saw was the co-main
event in the main event
alright so first of all UFC as a car it
was absolutely lit you know saying under
course I'm just gonna talk about some of
the key ones for me obviously yo Derek
Lewis versus the Russian cat I forget
his last name right now that was
arguably I could easily have been
fighting tonight great fight back and
forth he busted uh Derek alerts orbital
bone he would couldn't see like it was
it was looking bad for there was couple
of times but he just he's getting hit
he's completely turning away so I was
just ready to rip him like first with
your cardio is terrible and you're
looking bad and then in the third round
shot at the Budokan know what I'm
talking about yo he caught him with a
two-piece that was so crazy link this
boy bad and he was getting dominated
pretty much the whole fight a shout-out
to Dennis cuz he had one of the funniest
post intro intro interviews I've ever
seen like cuz if what you call it goes
up to him he's like yeah so how'd you
feel he's like yo Donna called me and
told me we got to get these Russians out
of here not even not of that I brought
up the heat wins like he takes his own
UFC fighting shorts well he just in his
boxes so they like what's up with that
he's eyeballs and
it was a crazy fight his post interview
was insane please watch this on youtube
it's everywhere he made a mint France's
and Ghana fight like this so sub cycle
of the chat black Fiji always got the
interviews see the thing is he still
looked bad and I was ready to rip him
like how you could still look bad after
the ink on him and I know he got caught
he thought it was a punk and her Dean
was just letting them rock so I'm just
right all right bad officiating all the
way around he looks bad I'm ready to go
off on him on Twitter and literally the
last round to peace he kept catching
with the right hand and then he
two-piece token Lincoln was crazy so
that was that yo fighting at night
though in my pin for get the main
Showtime versus your mains you know say
el Cucuy let me tell you right now that
was Tony Ferguson that was the fight of
the night
Showtime was looking like he was the one
with the crazy cauliflower Louis waited
till a second fight yeah definitely but
um yeah that was a fight of the night I
mean show time to like show Tom he
caught Tony in the beginning really
rocked Tony almost had him out of there
somehow to fight got stopped in the mid
because of arm a cut open on Showtime's
head but even though he wasn't really
hurt it would cut was that bad so once
they come result Tony got his legs and
let me tell you but you saw of his
Prussia game his walk you his I don't
care I don't care yes his I don't care
what you doing I'm on you like he that's
why I looked at on ok is he's in the
same division he's not most likely get
the winner O'Connor and Kabir and I'm
like okay now I see what people talk
about nobody was there one yeah yeah and
then like he could no he's coming off
the knee injury so he looked good and
Showtime was testing at me
so he was like whoa this you know see
how it's gonna go but that was a great
fight and then we get to the me eyes
with combat talk is he came laid it down
you know I'm saying I can't you wanna
start off homie started off with my
feeling like yes you did
told you I told you that boy get on the
floor and he swim he's feeling like a
fish in water three seconds into the
fight kind of throws a jab he said okay
cool slips to the left kind of goes to
throw the right guess who's on the floor
with Conor
he got nah bruh
kinda the whole night had the face that
everybody has a fight Floyd what what
the hell is going on yo his capture yo
two legs his capture of the two days he
doesn't let go he doesn't let go low
Cognito privy me to this little
information hmm the man's wrestles bears
as a baby no listen when I tell you
could be
wrestles bears as a baby and I said now
he's joking
no there's actual footage of your man's
wrestling of beer as a child mm-hmm as a
child like who puts their child to
wrestle a bit that's one his daddy crazy
that's one but all right and just
more insight to understanding exactly
his press conference at the end when he
said you don't talk about a man's
religion you don't talk about a man's
country hey don't talk about a man's
daddy boycott I did all three of those
things all right now he messed with
Russian gangsters Cana brought that up
yeah your boy he said he got finance he
was down with the movement kind of she
covers a flashy entertainment dude he's
entertainment dude remember Lord Cognito
remember when Evander Holyfield was
fighting Mike Tyson
this was the shades of the same thing
and we always knew me and cause me to
always know um Holyfield was gonna beat
the breaks off of Mike Tyson when it get
rough and ready mmm it was just gonna
happen
yeah only saw it inside that man there
was dog inside that man and he was going
to rip you apart give him the chance
I saw khabib I saw seven fights I said
that talk to Claude Cognito in the night
before I watched seven fights at him as
he asked me said what do you think I
said I gotta be respectful and watch
this really and I'm sitting I'm doing
the checkmarks and I said this man is
the devil I've done this man is not the
man that you want to be with because
every puzzle every Rubik's Cube that was
sent to him because they probably tried
to snipe him to get him outta there
because he's boring yeah he wins he's
boring he wins he solved it he changes
the Rubik's Cube every time for every
color to match you're not gonna beat him
unless he gets tired and old yes let me
jump in man cuz uh I thought the fight
was I was checking out how like
emotionally not these dudes came into
the ring and all that and I thought the
energy was good no saying on both sides
could be my confident kind of had his
little swag when he did the stretch I'm
like okay you know I'm saying so when
they get it on
you know actually talk kind of did a
good run so did you watch yeah
the first round did very well as far as
the better than I thought
and and actually although could be about
to take down I thought that Connor did
well
twice ramble out of the takedown and I
felt he didn't take any damage I felt he
wasn't exerting a lot of energy when he
was done okay
I watched the fight six times this
morning I fell asleep watching no there
there go look at it again he wasn't
caught anyone else ooh there he was late
the key was on him look he's making him
carry his weight so he's exerting some
some energy there but the fact that he
didn't take a lot of physical punishment
punches honestly I really think this guy
had a checklist like really I think he
was the decid istic that he had a
checklist and said he was gonna follow
this checklist until the finish him he's
definitely methodical that way I think
what surprised me is when he was willing
to stand what the moment he stood with
Connor he's because that's when I knew
the fight now is gonna hold in for
direction because first of all his ego
want to show the hell I'm not gonna run
from your stand-up - I gotta make you
respect me up here see that's the thing
when you catch a striker who if you're a
wrestler but you catch the striker the
striker now is messed up you ever say
emotion because now he's got a look at
the takedown and he's got a look at you
don't say if you're gonna you get so
completely round to change to fight that
that the cracking of Connor big time and
then the only thing I was gonna saying
I'll let you go solve is that round
three actually thought first could be my
little girl
Connor did good for getting up he was
tired and I was okay get him take down
so they could be like who's Sloane a
little bit that was the only chance in
my opinion Connor had to win round three
you know say after that he did his stand
his stamina was done
and and I got a caller I got a caller
how I got a call he saw like a king he
quit he wanted out of it
he is suit it wasn't even a serious
choke it was a similar neck crank
I'm saying crank get not saying that
don't hurt all choked out you could
breathe he could breathe he while we saw
it all ABS because when they finally got
him down he's tired he wants out I got a
call I got a call that you know why why
cuz Connor has been he's been quoted
many times saying you know what nobody
can stop me in there all day and as soon
as Nate got around that neck done as if
you if you count yourself as the number
one I get that I get that but he's not
that dude exactly what the mouth God can
he kick you out shout the Bisbing he get
lean down or you choking on with that
yep alright listen I'm gonna give you
the skinny on your man Connor kind of
got fat off those mayweather bucks when
he was standing up there at the weigh-in
I'm not looking at the dudes butt but I
saw chica CH right his cheek was too
heavy as his butt yeah too much but me
I'm doing I were in sort know and trust
me I went and saw previous fight night
and I said mmm that's it the way and he
made weight but the weight wasn't super
conditioned weight and for a fight where
if he was off with striking because it
looked like he was off every time he
tried to time him to get him where wit
with a strike like he'll land the strike
but it was like a couple of seconds of
milliseconds off and I told you if he's
milliseconds off of this and can beam is
actually able to counter which he
did cuz he threw the right and could be
counted with his right and dropped them
and I said Oh God
I said this oh sorry I said this is it
right here because like Lord kognito
said when you strike a striker
that's an extra fear I saw fear in the
eyes of Connor he had to walk it off he
tried to show some privado in the fight
that show yeah well and said he looked
at a character that is normal you know
we know I got personal
listen Roberson let's get into the lat
the real reason which is you know the
aftermath
you know I've you know obviously shout
out to all Fonzarelli Mike Ibarra God
what you call my boy yard
doctor what's his name doc from xboxes
my home and we were talking everyone was
talking last night and and j-dub and you
know I felt strongly about it and here's
the thing you know what people are like
yo and I've seen you shot some not on my
timeline a like yo you know we can't get
mad it could be just look at what kind
of day look at the bus and all that but
his word y'all lose me my thing is
listen yeah both was doing gangsta ish
pride right
one of y'all con it I mean you could be
too did whole thing started Kings Cubs
dudes rolled up I'm saying Connor got
the word he threw the private jet out he
came at the 40 goons that's how the
busting started he told me to come out
whatever he didn't come out or whatever
that's how the bus didn't kind of gets
locked up right let's not forget that
chronic is locked up he got it a 3.5
million right word
then who comes to this joint you know
Connors talkin reckless what am I about
his family his religion not saying
that's right I get it
my thing is you just proved to the world
khabib you're that dual right you
destroyed is do you smell you made him
quit in I had no problem with him
standing over I'm talking had no problem
had no problem I'm like you know why
because they they had their beef outside
and then went in and they fought the
fair want anything for a favor
you may just do quick right boom then
you go over you throw the mouthpiece had
to do and I still got no problem with
that
now when you jump out do some summer
so kick whatever you do with the veins
and the pig that I've seen from the top
broke that wasn't part of WWE in my life
you shout out to kabhi kick comes out he
did it on with the BJJ Kaunas BJJ got
right what are you doing for him then
you get back your man's now one jumps
over the rope to set to set it on Connor
kind of spits out or whatever they about
to get it popping then his other man's
jumps in its toll on Connor from behind
right what are y'all really doing I get
it emotions is high dude is wild
disrespectful with the mouth you beat
him he was talking crate I get that but
here's where you lose me one don't mess
with the money your purse is revoked now
your purse is revoked now you're not
from this country
your visa now your peoples is locked you
don't say the end toward himself it's
fighters they're fighters they'd already
said they're never fighting on UFC again
you just blew your cash now you're
stealing it we still even get the word
from the Nevada State Athletic
Commission because at the end of the day
dudes getting suspended that's fact
so at the end Cubs getting suspended so
whether it's going to be six months or
first year and if it's a year guess what
they're stripping him so what they think
about what you really doing here now if
this one a pure gangster level I get
from you know where we're from we
understand what that was we know what
that King I know what you're about to
say we know what that was and from
Street rules justify I get that but you
gotta be bigger than that you messing
with the money this is your moment and
you ruined it that's just how I feel
about it that's them right
exactly from the heart and exactly from
the heart is what you're saying is true
you're talking from the Dana White
position and I normally I'm on my Dana
White
you know ish I'm sitting there like yo
keep that money cool still do it nah you
this is the way you beat a bully you
kinda can never talk again in that ring
oh no question I know you use it the bus
use on a bus action again you're selling
the location you know okay and he said
and the whole time could be was a
gentleman all the way dude till he got
him in that rainy said I catch during
the fight the whole beat down in the
second round when he was Lumpa dumping
him in a corner when he was standing
over raining bombs from heaven what
topic on his head I know what he was
doing he was dragging his soul out his
body I'm about what happened afterwards
you might say man that's messed up King
people could have been hurt exactly let
me tell you something let me tell you
something I don't like people that run
their mouth and then when action happens
I mean about that action Conner was cool
he got beat up inside the ring was
nothing happening to Connor Connor
climbed up on top of the top rope he saw
his man's fighting he saw a beams man up
there he looked and said I'm a snuffin
he got his snuff on could be man
mmm-hmm started to proceed to hit him
Kabhi brother saw from outside what
common both of the back they proceeded
to work that man over because he didn't
learn what happened in the ring this is
third stuff
no to beep when you take a guy and his
adrenaline is high yes I agree you can't
force somebody who is in Spanish mode
and you keep antagonizing him he threw
his mouthpiece he faked out the Red
Guard and got over there and gave you
two feet to your head
shoutout to the Doodle called the two
feet in the mouth the governor was Putin
for four : could be right after said I
got your bail money it's good it's a
goal his fighting crispers is not a goal
in commission
you know going on your sword like I tell
you before nobody's beating that man
yeah he he unnecessarily made himself a
villain I got you but he said he can't
maintain that mantle mmm
Khurana can maintain the mantle nice
himself right now
that's not exactly who he is right crazy
so Khan ain't even press charges you
know he could have pressed charge yeah
it was like yo you want like King said
Conner should not after this fight he
should not be able to say another word
hey why what could be bid
he gave him that uprising again exact
because now what every night so about
your rebirth
the way he beat him at his corner what
he told you we're not saying it cuz he
was unapologetic to make a bull don't
ever move to a real thug about his
religion about his father and about his
country
cuz a real thug is gonna break you down
inside and outside see just always
understand its repercussions for that
that's all you got understandably
because like at the end of the day he's
okay for those repercussions like me to
Conner based on everything I went
through and he gonna feel that work I
get it I know what it is like to be
completely honest with you like this the
stuff that Connor did with that bus if
that would have been anyone else they
would have been out and shout out the
j-dub cuz it made a point which is and
the UFC let's be real they've been
enabling Conner and that they use that
independent but is fine so we gotta keep
that we can't absolve them they've been
they've been benefiting off the Connor
train be honest with you I'm not down
for Connor getting no repercussions all
right the the he but he hit that
importers
[Music]
I would have just sat there didn't hit
that dude died dude what to jumped over
the fence cuz he saw his mouth the first
part of investing meaning take Conners
purse okay revoking I get that by the
end of the day that they were looking
more at the dude who jumped over which
they should yeah
and I just like repercussions for not
even he wasn't even part of jumping over
the fence he tried to jump over the
fence but they grabbed him first and
then when he couldn't do it he get to do
for no reason and he got no
repercussions you know that dude got
down off the fans I personally don't
think he should his fighting career
should be over for that that wasn't his
fault that Connor hit is that they
didn't did he say that right now it is
the investigation so Dana White said
that people who jumped in that photo
they're going there died again I
personally I agree with the one that
gave that gave Connor that body pieces I
agree with that is that do jump over
there specifically they're all dead
little over them jumping holes in green
you can't do that dude who threw the
dolly into the bus into the window that
beach in the never Ford again but
bringing that he being that he's
bringing bucks to the ring I get it he
went over there he jumped on top of that
he wasn't causing no one no issues you
held up with your English that you
approach a dude you gonna get stolen he
didn't approach him he was gay when he
approached it Connor Frank Khanna
snuffed oh no he didn't even see him
there he wasn't even listen so let's get
it to this page is wrong let's go time
to pay the bills that time of month one
thing
as you guys are fully aware the iron
bank I really appreciate everyone you
know I've been noticing the increase and
I appreciate everyone they are really
sources like luck on the rail I do
appreciate that thank God as you guys
are fully aware the iron bank is
susceptible to influence of the monetary
persuasions if that uh PayPal is not on
fleek you are not in the running with
that out of the way let's start off with
lord cory lydic himself Lord whiskey
thank you so much for the whiskey the
PlayStation brah to the new canoe
brawling away I seen it Russ coming
Kareem oh yeah congratulations brought
Nick yeah that's right yes
congratulations Lord Kareem H thank you
for the support
much appreciated well now salut
Corrine's that's the new joint yeah
absolutely mm-hmm Lord Chris Williams
thank you so much Oh Tallulah hello
Thank You monkey punch himself Lord you
the lord of back compat himself mr. bill
still well thank you salute protected a
roommate did Great Wall loop Lord Ricky
Moore yes second weekend up in page
Thank You Ricky thank you so much Lord
Spoonman noche Fonz - two and a half
weeks and Counting til greatness arrives
oh yeah right
we got the stream teams on Lord snow doe
you know check out Hicks come review man
very good as up in our podcast channel
yo I got it I gotta give him the biggest
guy first
I just gotta give them the biggest and
the craziest utmost respect I love the
way that you have taken control over
certain things and you worked your way
sir I do salute you and I probably don't
say it as much because I had to mute
that chat because you're losing their
everything you and l-boogie is like the
groove and I really appreciate you and I
want to shout out shout Chris Williams
aka Lord fast bet that's who that oh
that's fast back that's our tick
brethren and I'm saying n LG fam always
always in a chair always been supportive
from day one salut let's go for it oh we
have next Lord loaded picks those the
color sister gray bro since kindergarten
with me I know he was in the chat he had
to go what I did Thank You Lord cat
daddy
um Lord snail killer himself Diago he's
a dissolute go what's up that's my guy
oh he's talking sports give me a mess
about - lord of intros the Lord death
singing hymn we got in last and
absolutely not least the lord of coating
himself lord Optimas cold [ __ ] was
you're a policewoman saloon is called og
schoolhouse channel check out his
channel he's always got super
entertaining content winning this is
Game one so we have a game giveaway
listen to our other game giveaway so yes
somebody might get that read it paid for
it alright let's go let's get so let's
start out with this $10 gift card
giveaway and that $10 gift card goes to
Lord spoon man boom in and that's what's
know all right all right so give me a
second I have to remove certain Lords
from this cuz guys I just want to
reiterate just be cognizant of your
tears like you know just so you know
that certain things you once you're once
that here is it spoken on then we move
forward and we have to remove certain
people now the $20 gift card giveaway
and that goes to Lord monkey punch
Michael now we have our t-shirt giveaway
okay
a song by my name give away sit Jane
Fonda rebel and Optimus code one
something and he pushed it forward and
don't you write matter of fact it was
Optimus cool yes yes salute no j-bone
expose one like three times
good point
Congrats to all the winners guys just
hit me up on a DM and we'll get those
codes out yeah he pre-ordered it already
so
and probably want something else well
guys I can't reiterate enough thank you
so much for all the support everybody
every single month the numbers have been
slowly growing thank you so much the one
thing I ask of you guys is appreciate
you guys being here every Sunday
supporting us supporting us on patreon
much appreciated for word man pushed it
forward talk about the podcast talk
about the podcast the people that you
don't think me may have heard of us get
the word out there man like really like
you guys the support you guys give us on
a monthly basis weekly basis is
absolutely amazing to us and we just
want to continue to continue for that to
grow so again thank you so much for
everything you guys do absolutely and
I'm just gonna double down on what Sava
saying and also I now to our special
announcement first of all thanks to all
the patreon subscribers it really means
a lot that you got support us listen to
our foolishness data without combat
today but oh yeah so thanks for that but
I definitely want to do a little
hehehehe with the state of the realm so
um I know North songs made it a point to
keep the patreon subscribers in I hope
you supporters inform and up speed so
one of the number requests that we've
got from you guys and you know we're
finally happy to make it happen is we're
happy to announced and we've been
working with teespring
and the iron lower podcast storefront is
now live with all your ILP royal swag
needs please check that out I'm gonna
put the link in the description BAM is
live go get that man we got everything
for you guys you know I'm saying and as
far as I'm holding and female Lords the
kids you know I'm saying the accessories
you know we've been thinking about the
color waves and all that stuff as well
so it's up if you want to support and I
know like I said a lot of you guys did
initially but I'll also a lot of guys
missed because they were like hey what's
up with that link so we hear you it is
live
it's called first way was gonna be
called the realm of the Lords we check
it out we got everyone covered and thank
you for your patience on that it really
means a lot to see reppin that Island
Lord shield nice
thank you the legacy we thought about
the we got a lot of flavors in though
I'm adoring multiple times and in a chat
and it really really means a lot to see
you guys proud wearing the coat wearing
the gear we're the crest we're an aisle
or shield you are now in the realm of
the Lord so thank you in salute and look
out for more interesting takes on this
stuff coming down the pipe yes it's not
only gonna be the shield I know the
shield's become we go look we gotta get
a shot out of the business girls asking
about iron Lords panties there's
actually been some stuff that's been
coming off on Twitter since the podcast
started apparently it looks like they're
hiring for multi players a lot of people
now think Killzone was coming out and
another thing
crackdown 3 has a release date on the
website for the 28th of February says
look like it's been delayed a little bit
okay so that's a lace from the crackdown
on that day at least give it a week out
of two weeks right maybe the leaked days
gone and you have Metro that
have a few other things yeah alright all
reason why they did not got the business
out the way all that good stuff thanks
for breaking news Eric let's get into
lady L bogie her video game system
history her journey as a protector of
the realm in the United States name and
of course when that had the becoming
members of both the grown woman gaming
and nerditude movements so lady boogie
let's start from the very beginning what
was some of the first video game systems
you had we got to negate so uh my dad
had me playing the Atari controller
really but my first console that was
like my own console was the Nintendo
playing on the wall yeah so that was the
beginning of my video game journey but
I've had pretty much every system like
throughout the years or like my cousin
had it so I got to play through the
super ten though the Dreamcast the Sega
like the original Sega I had one second
dogs yeah game boys I had the PS Vita
I've had everything really like what
about what about some of them than these
consoles what about like the UM like the
turbo graphics 16 or maybe like a video
and that's kind of pricey I mean you
know being like poor don't you see this
anywhere yeah but I
I wish that I was able to keep a lot of
those you know because now you look back
and you're like I wish I had all these
you know but um yeah I'm gonna start
trying to collect them again maybe back
in realist I'll check my heart that i'ma
go get me back my turbo duel and go get
my super graphics and I'm gonna start
building back my new mom
NEC collection I saw the prices that
they was trying to rape me for I said I
could go back and buy him at regular
prices I said they raping people stole
from my nostalgia I'm not gonna pay the
price for that I'm as many consoles that
come out probably the most that I spent
the most hours and I guess is what I
would say and that was probably the
Gamecube of all things right so I had
the Gamecube and I think that I spent
the most hours on it a monkey ball a
ball so I don't know I played a lot of
that and in the OG xbox like I played a
lot of that playing a game called to be
some og fighting game what they had a
general owner never flop what is going
on I played that a lot and I also played
their volleyball game was soft porn was
not advisable for kids that was bad they
would take pitches and mail or Cognito
was very
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes and then probably my most memorable
console would be the PlayStation 2
only because I remember it being such a
thing it was like such a deal about
everywhere it was expensive as hell and
it was still sold out everywhere but the
thing was is that my dad kept telling me
oh you can't get it it's sold out I
can't find it it's too much money and in
Christmas Day gifting any specific
PlayStation 2 game stood out for you
that generation knows I think the game
that I'm thinking about is PlayStation 3
Go Go Heavenly Sword I'm so you thank
you i remember playing Metal Gear Solid
a lot I think of when I hear see that
game is that noise you know
yeah like everything I play everything
I've always sleep football games I see a
beast in man 2003 but anymore I think
they've given us way too much control
yeah you know some love it almost got
overwhelming we I kind of miss other
than somebody ties with the Capri
homework ballots like you get control
every aspect of life but after being in
the military's when I really got into
the FPS okay I'm sorry no no you're fine
ask you that because um obviously you
know what the Lord's around we know you
for you know is that xbox love and a lot
of FPS we know you get busy using
destiny I know you got me I got shot in
the head to dance but now yous getting
busy and obviously he'll stop all that
stuff so um tell me like how your
affinity for Xbox are because you know a
lot of people know you and the Xbox
family the Xbox brand like you are a
mainstay so like how did that really
take off for you so really it took off
like while I was in the military so I
was like I had a friend who worked with
me and he like begged me to get a 360
like and this was for to enter the gym
this was maybe like 2012 2011 and he
begged me to get one and I'm like you
know I wasn't in FPS or anything he's
like look I'm gonna play with you don't
worry we don't get battlefield 4
everything's gonna be gravy we're gonna
set you up with a headset so he really
walk me through playing battlefield and
then he got me into like all the
communities and stuff in like in the
military is nothing but a community like
everywhere is within your so like I
worked at the Naval Hospital mm-hmm so
that's your community but that's your
bigger community but then you're within
your big community I had my actual like
office where I was at which was fleet
liaison and what we were we were the
liaison between the fleet in the
hospital okay then you had that little
community so I'm already really
community oriented he introduced to me
in a more community and I feel like Xbox
as I know I'm gonna catch heat but they
have this community like I've met people
that I've never met before in real life
but they're still like family like sex
yeah that is such a big statement and
again I know a lot of people like you
said couldn't give crap or whatever
because the end of it you know obviously
we know Xbox is opera for a console but
right thing that people don't realize
and I'm glad you said that is not only
do they have my opinion some of the best
community like the execs everyone it
comes from a place like a true gaming
place right and I feel that's different
I'm not trying to disrespect the
community or the Nintendo communities
it's just that the events and like you
said like this peak like when I met you
ever my first like I met inferno and all
that through you and it's just so cool
it's almost like a fraternal thing right
we get together every year to see our
family almost and that's what a lot of
people outside of the community don't
understand but continue yeah but there's
like something to be said too about a
sense of community like what the Xbox
they like make you feel like you're
important which people don't put enough
stock into everyone needs to feel
important that's happy but it's like
human nature to feel like you're one
[Laughter]
because I met you as well and I honestly
have to say I play on PlayStation and
I'm is really isolated box be honest
with you mostly in the single-player
game so it's really like in the bushes
in the corners I believe and when when
you do get to have any interaction with
other people it's really aggressive
antagonistic typing things um Microsoft
which I've noticed their games a lot of
cooperative games and the fact that the
Xbox Live is probably always up number
two down like PlayStation Network got my
my hair but I don't care um and the
communication is definitely there
because we have parties we literally you
know we have lobbies sometimes there'd
be 12 people in there and we got a
branch off from Vallejo come on we gotta
go play this or Pub G let's leave out of
here and I sent you an invite all we
sent monkey invited will slide off and
go over there to keep that over there
but the community group is still there
and it just like branched off into
different little sections and I think
that's cultivated more at Microsoft
because when Mike Ibarra can jump inside
your party or Phil is somebody actually
playing with you and actually
communicating what you play and see if
thieves or something like that which is
a cooperative game within itself and
it's in-game pass how they'll start out
um it fosters this family type of
atmosphere and I and I get that you know
because like it was a period where I
didn't play video games at all because I
was you know people tease you they act
like especially for a female like what
is wrong with you that you play video
games like there has to be something
wrong with you it has to be some
character flaw on why a female would
want to play video games like right so
it was a big period where I missed a lot
of games because I didn't play Wow then
I got back into it like I said you know
more so once I was in the military but
it wasn't until I got the Xbox that I
really got into playing because there
was community was there people there was
easy to find people who are like-minded
and to play with said PlayStation is
very isolated it's hard to like find
people that are like-minded like you
just offer the system itself you know
what I mean right
no I hate what you say a lot better now
they're doing much better yeah
definitely what I felt where they did is
they actually took a page from the 360
right war is the party chats and you
know community going because that was
something that Xbox was always ahead of
them so again we don't we're not trying
to the chat we see how we're not trying
to make it a PlayStation bash I took the
PlayStation and I
have all the Playstations so like people
think because Xbox is my my preferred
console that I hate PlayStation in like
no that's not the case and I don't buy
into this BS console or like you guys
need to find something else to do with
your life talk about it but yeah so
that's really that's really my story I
mean I don't really have too much I'm a
mom to graduating this this December
with my degree in information systems my
degree and my hope is to work for
Microsoft that's be the best Community
Manager for you guys she will be
important she will be you you're a
fantastic on the stream team really
appreciate what you do and I wish watch
ask you one last question for you one
which was more about the grown women
gaming and nerdy - yeah
so like I want to shout out your team
I'm saying less infamous ladies you're
saying of course your boys in law
prophecy yes yes so how did you get
started with the whole grown woman
gaming movement and then I also want to
salute you too because you were on like
a pan or in the crowd of a panel at at
e3 it's the gray isle piece meant a lot
to us you have no idea how much that
meant so I want to salute you on that
you know as far as diversity you know
say you know women of color movement as
well as the grown women gaming and nerds
how did that whole start I mean that's
like like you heard what I was just
saying like a super report to me really
because like I was shamed about my video
copy you know to me so like in we
complain about how the characters don't
look like us how there's not enough like
options so like make that avatars look
like this and how are we gonna have that
if you have have only one set of people
trying to make something that they don't
know about like you expect expect a
bunch of white males to be able to
really capture what black hair looks
like
but black facial features are like just
our pictures alone we know that there is
not two different types of shades right
you know what I mean it's not black and
blacker and that's it they come in all
different shades we're not going to be
able to get there unless we have more
females more people of color all colors
in the gaming industry in if I can do
something to help that I feel like it's
a necessity for me to do that that was
you and I love your question for sale
you know saying when you out there but
the guys on stage like that was really
cool very positive yeah and I'm a mother
too so that helps as well so when I see
my daughter and I see her really
enjoying the video games as well I think
okay so how am I going to expose her to
more coding to more aspects of the video
game industry besides just playing the
games that she can thrive with well
there's large girls that cold movements
everywhere but I think that because Xbox
is so community centered that they have
a platform to really do some good and
that rest was not every company it's
trying to do good they just try and get
your money
mm-hmm now see you that's a great point
fantastic point and just real quick so
then you just linked up with all like
the grown woman gaming specifically like
how did you link up who started what
lady contacted me after oh I can't
remember when but she did cut reach out
to me and we started playing heavily and
then we got the Lyle on board because
they do grg together know Doug and
Delilah brought Charisse okay we started
and we started a little slow but I think
we're starting to gain a little traction
now so we kept with it
Delilah came with with the nice graphics
for you know we have our own dedicated
channel now on you yeah we're gonna keep
moving toward that I would like to get
some more
people that because we all are primarily
Xbox so let's to weeks ago where we have
some people who are more Nintendo since
you're okay okay it's nice to have that
banter oh we got calls Avila you gotta
call solve up for that good dynamic of
people who like different things you
know so because no one wants to hear you
just everybody agreeing all the time I
mean I play with proxy I joined prophecy
back when the division was happening I
join a Facebook and I play with him and
it's you're like apprehensive you don't
know how dudes are going to be with
females but absolutely he's he's the
best he's the best guy he doesn't mind
helping people he's starting his no
Turner nerditude and we're just waiting
for him to get his PC and then we're
gonna be rocking off with the nerditude
nurse was gonna be more everything anime
oh you know everything yes I watched
anime too it was you know lady Felicity
chat love right there we definitely want
to support you because at the end of the
day you know saying like that growing
the game is so important see out here
moving you know sound listen to it a
couple times and you guys really know
you gaming and I like when they put your
order you're doing your report from e3
how it down NBA and what's funny is not
like I know exactly what you want to say
we've been in those you know those
environments so it's just so cool and I
really go back up there before the end
of the year for hand but
and yes so I've been there it's amazing
it's like Disneyland for videogames yes
it is the Lord's will definitely try to
get there the goal is 2019 to get that
that's a salute l boogie so of course
you in the room so you know I gotta ask
you the question and I asked all the
guests tough question top five video
game all tab all right well the
franchise number one is gonna be Tomb
Raider because I played today on my on
my PC nice and man super throwback to
the sims I was building your sewage
plant next to your water plant so we got
those two we got too many PC gaming PC
all right and then I have to go with the
Mario franchise like that's like been
with me forever
like II just like as a child beginning
to the end and trying to make sure you
get at the top of that flag came to
change my life your personal friends is
we don't can't judge me free okay
everybody's gonna hate me let's go
but I'm gonna go with destiny well
Michael let's go
right
but I guess yeah I was like I love the
axe I don't know if people can see but
there's notes from Halo in there there's
notes from Star Wars which is like my
favorite movie franchise people probably
don't even see it in there but it's
there the people who are creating a game
love Star Wars mm-hmm and bonds me
listen they listen to people I mean but
they were activating I don't quite like
because I think that they're just like
so money hungry that they mess up our
game sometimes but they're pretty quick
to fix it yeah so yeah so I mean cuz
I've just put so many hours into destiny
I need you to explain why is it that
destiny keeps bringing you back what is
it about the hook what is it about
specifically about the I got a challenge
a little because we we get a lot of heat
as destiny lovers right right people get
try to need to understand what is it
about this damn game you guys keep
coming back and keep spending money like
what is it about this there's like such
a satisfaction when you get something
that's no one else has or that you
people have because you know that when
you're in that space where everyone can
see you and you have that you know
that winner or whatever hand cannon and
was like oh I haven't I haven't gotten
that or I haven't been able to beat that
like that's why they fell off for the
Meganium Destiny too because it was too
easy
like if I don't have to do the raid why
am I gonna do the raid right so there's
like a satisfaction that comes with the
grind I mean if the game is not perfect
at all in any way shape or form I'm not
saying that it is but it definitely has
a satisfaction to it because you grind
you put in work like and then you get a
prize at the end what what about that
completo how about oh yeah it has the
best gameplay ever hands down
I think that's pretty much what brings
me back to is that like the gunplay is
just like so awesome
yeah on point like just nobody
nobody else in the industry has gunplay
like that like that was one of my
biggest pet peeves about the latest Tomb
Raider is that how is it better to shoot
with the bowl that is good what I've
noticed this new trend
um and I don't know if it was term rated
that started that trend with the bow
yeah but it's like everybody's been
capitalizing on that trend with the
block is now if you don't have a bow in
the game you know um but they got the
mechanics down so I'm good with it
I think they slacked off on the actual
gunplay and then I always use the bow
from now on like when I'm playing it
seems so natural mm-hmm it's like you
don't even want to use anything else
about the bow which I mean I I think
you're right I think that when they did
the initial reboot was when everybody
started oh this bow thing everybody's
liking it oh yeah no doubt that's what's
up and number five was the fifth and run
out the list I was hoping that you
forgot know that we were per means a lot
oh yeah means a lot to me I don't know
any system any time frame could be
recent could be back in a day I wish
that back like Nintendo like you would
have many console with just your light
gun and give the light gun games that's
a Nintendo Wii so question about that
ducking cuz I heard when you mentioned
it before you said you were playing it
on the wall so you're playing on our
projector yeah yeah I don't know I
remember how my mom did it you know but
I had one great great history though
you're gonna show would Alice now spy or
attic leave he's here for staying the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent announcement by Sony to allow
for tonight cross play between multiple
platforms is it fair to now expect
Bethesda to include Fallout 76 cross
play based on their previous
non-negotiable stands involving cross
play for Elder Scrolls legends the
winner at 67% of the vote was the yes
Sony has now exposed but there's this
previous statement and called their
bluff group cover their that second
place at only 26 percent was the no only
expectation for Bethesda based on the
time frame with Sony announcement group
and coming in at a shallow third place
with only 7% of the vote was I don't
care who's playing buggy bethesda games
anyway l-boogie what do you think about
the Bethesda stone II think it's only
called their bluff what did you feel
about the whole thing
it still remains to be seen
when it comes out and everybody has
cross play as Sony doesn't are they
gonna bend again mhm
just like are their consumer is gonna be
like alright Sony like no I have to keep
buying [ __ ] on your console you know
everybody else's consoles separately
right so I don't know like I think
Bethesda is pushing forward I think that
it'd be great I'd love to be able to
play all my games and have cross
progression and all that mm-hmm
I'm because then you'd be able to play
with your friends play with your friends
on Xbox so for you I'd love to see it I
don't I mean the reason why they don't
want you to do is because there
good grab the money absolutely now here
we see what happened I thought it was
funny was a very hot topic so what we
are going to get into this so on we got
some breaking news um hot off the
presses so there's a ton of impact a lot
of all huge PlayStation rumors this week
and room number was kind of broken by
Jason Schreyer from kotaku and he's
basically saying that um game developers
are prepping for PSNH changes so that is
out there in the universe as far as all
different games two-year-olds you know
it's been long overdue
you know they've confirmed that in rumor
number two which was very interesting
was definitely about PlayStation 5
backward compatibility and Sony's
recently registered a patent that
heavily suggests that that arm it's
gonna be their focus and apparently this
could be for applying to all the
Playstations of the past generation the
original one PlayStation 2 3 and 4 and
basically what they determine with this
patent is about this asset that's called
a texture and in score four it's
basically a texture for legacy software
so what they've basically I use these
identifiers to show that this is
something that as an asset that could be
remastered and be a part of a new
console game presentation again sounds
very similar to the backward
compatibility and then on the last one
which is pretty much about you know the
release date and obviously you know with
PS 5 I mean PSX was kind of like a
no-show we know about the e3 situation
you know this some rumors going on and I
want to shout out on a Security's that's
one of them Express Co a lot of these
guys Kotaku also um actually comic book
Doc Holliday has something on it as well
which is also about the PS 5 and there's
they're saying that they say they at
least expect it to be introduced in 2019
not necessarily the launch yet but you
know it introduced so I wanted to bring
this to the realm you know with these
rumors kind of picking up only one I
would consider very more legit which
would be the Jason fryer kataka one
because those are from specific game
developers who are choosing to speak
anonymously about Sony's backward I mean
name changes you know kind of things
that won't we
we'll say is more hopeful consequent the
one that he's supposed to do on the rim
confirm no we're gonna confirm that one
right there
well the other two obviously you know we
have to get more sources on it which is
the back compare and the PSR come
so yes King you know how you feel this
is the case and if these rumors are true
things to the Lord is the ps5 set up to
dominate next gen the biggest thing for
them has been though back compact and if
they're going to be bringing a new
console this early mm-hmm like try to
get the jump which I've heard rumors
that the dev kits are already out mm-hmm
people have difficult in hand know if
the deaf kids are out and people are
already working toward this system then
back compact would be the only way that
they could be successful
mm that's a big deal that's a big deal
right it's too fresh you know yeah
absolutely and to be able to could carry
those games forward ie so that would be
the bigger rumor now what about the year
release date about you know where will
you sit on whether it comes out 2019 you
know 2020 what what's your gut telling
you I think they're gonna announce it at
e3 and release it in 2019 oh you think
it's announced this year and release
this year 2019 I'm sorry correct my
honest opinion
I'm low-key starting to think the way
these companies are moving that uh we're
gonna get an announcement of XO III is
gonna be dedicated to the next gen games
and that comes out next year bring it
all the way around Lord solve I need you
on three rumors back compact name
changes and PS 5 release date first of
all I give a big shout out to Sony for
always pushing the envelope and being
first in line for something I've never
heard of this before back and back what
is that I never heard that and who wants
that
I mean I'm floored by this this
innovative thing that I've never heard
of before
sarcasms I don't like I've been saying
it for the longest I think they need to
follow suit with Microsoft in that
regard in order to truly be successful
next next-gen because the thing about it
is I just think regardless of how many
places and consoles are out there
Microsoft has continued to push the
envelope in terms of making the argument
that their console is is of the best a
great Buy all the way around with all
the services game passed with everything
it just it doesn't make sense that they
would not go that route I know where
King is coming from treated
they've never traditionally done stuff
like that because that then we they
don't want to be perceived as the guys
that follow behind but there's a certain
thing it's too much work to create a
separate ecosystem for their legacy
stuff it's just too much work so my
thinking is that it's gonna happen oh I
don't know go ahead I have a question
with you know the direction they're
taking PlayStation now do you think they
try to use that as their legacy they
could be using this back with
compatibility to make it where you can
download these games on the service and
not have to strain them all right no
assuming it's not gonna be the thing to
me the downloading thing the back
compare true back comp at I think at
some point they have they have to figure
that the downloading stuff is imperative
that they're not I'm talking about they
had they could be researching this
method so they can make it where they
can download these ps3 games these ps2
games these ps1 games oh yes now like I
but I think as a service is gonna be on
the console whatever the console is is
still gonna
beyond the console where I would hope
that they would you know choose that
direction that they would give people
that option but you know the way they've
been acting this generation I see them I
see them like look like we got a PS 5
for the PS 5 titles you can subscribe to
this PlayStation now for such-and-such
month and you can play all the rest yeah
this off because most rubbers in the
chase said PS 5 and 2019 why would they
release their next gen console before
last of us part to go sistema and -
straining release we said before a lot
of games are probably cross-gen games
you'll see two versions of these games
and another thing is if if they really
want to be super bold if NIT and it
holds true that these consoles are
coming next year
imagine a launch lineup with that like
if you really want to put the nail in
Microsoft Office like if you really want
to do if you really really want to come
hard mm-hmm don't care about spreading
out these releases over the course of
you know 2019 and 2020 you just drop all
that and then say what I'm Jason
Voorhees I'm in the bushes I'm chasing
you down ain't gonna happen
it's over you're not getting out of
heads over is it horror movie and guess
what happens there's no backup at
anything happen now if you want to play
our stuff and this is a business right
Dave winning without doing it Microsoft
is doing it and they're losing so
they're looking and said that's not a
good idea but we don't have to waste
money on it recently registered a patent
there's a lot of patents that get
registered there's a ton of patents that
get registered that never come to
fruition it's not coming but the other
service they have a surface and that
service
they have invested so much in
PlayStation now just like lordotic said
that that makes sense
like what I'm gonna download it to the
system yeah you say you know what I like
about game past let's copy that let's
download at our system to make sense I
really I think they're smart for how
many times the system does go offline so
you can actually play some games that
you pay a for for a month I feel that do
that I would think that that I mean at
the end of the day like you know these
are big corporations that they do this
research and development long before
like whatever they're doing on the PS 5
it's been in research for a while right
so that's what a lot of people forget
about when it comes to games some of
these they're like well why didn't they
put this trend in there this trend
because is this this development cycle
started four years ago you know I think
that the if I were to bet I would say
that they would but at the end of the
day it's like Pia you know they're
making these moves of PS now they've
kept that service alive
I really wouldn't be surprised that
they're like look the PS 5 you have
access to all these games but if you
want to play our odor library we can
give you this service where you could
pay a certain amount of dollars or maybe
they'll restructure PS now and you can
play these I don't think I don't think
that's the best move for them I think
that would hurt them a lot but I
wouldn't be surprised that they did it
right so are you saying that what you
shame the service wouldn't be playable
on the PS 5 no it'll be it would be I
never said it was asking you know it's
gonna be on the PS 5 I'm saying that if
you want to play ps4 ps3 PS 2 and ps1
games there's nothing like you could
subscribe to PlayStation now and play
those games
continue continue King I want you to
finish a point back compat like Xbox
like if you own the game already you'll
be
okay when using this backwards
compatibility you know I hope that
they're doing it because I honestly
think if they choose that direction that
they don't want they don't need true but
you know native backwards compatibility
on the ps5 they're gonna get murdered by
just the market DC Malone by Microsoft
right like imagine marketing it's like a
play play xbox to whatever it is and
play four generations of games like
that's hard to not reach out to market
against yeah would think that they would
do it you know they would set the
backwards compatibility they have been
you know reversing a lot of things here
lately they've been saying like the the
cross play exactly like I said I would
expect that they're gonna care more
about this service called PlayStation
now than they do backwards compatibility
natively on the PS 5 we've you know 100%
in agreement they tried their native
crap and it didn't work out for them um
everybody's keep sight in this this old
yo they just bend the knee got they bend
the knee to the biggest dude in the game
the biggest doodle game made them Benny
honestly what I really do like when you
really get smack smack so hard your ears
started ringing
they got smacked and that ear was
ringing and it was like exactly what he
said y'all could play over there too and
I listened I I I'm pretty much can tell
you look at all the future games that
come out it's not gonna be no cross we
can play and these dudes really don't
care they don't care about it like the
PlayStation dudes is like we're fine
over here
the hell it's all just like that like so
the guys that are clamoring for it it's
really the most progression is better oh
absolutely
I'm completely with ya cross-play who
cares right I really don't care but
cross progression and I would love to
actually break up my playstation and
play my destiny I really love to do that
the problem with cross progression is
that by definition then you have to it
forces you to pick aside more than
anything else right because then it's
like okay are you really gonna buy three
copies of this game to play on different
platforms
it feels streamer yes you're right yes
oh and then you don't think solve they
they're more worried about if if these
companies can prove I mean the
engagement and just like you know almost
like the game pass thing like you know
that more people are spending and more
people doing might you know send any
we're getting more popular and online
communities are thriving you know I'm
saying I think maybe they can come with
that sale on cross progression but I
think it probably you know like like
King said I think fortnight is the
anomaly in this gen okay cause it
biggest dude but like next gen maybe you
know they can be able to double down
more those are the companies and now
that the floodgates open source people
yeah I think I think for tonight is
definitely anomaly I don't know that we
see a game be able to do that again and
then and then it's another thing you
have to worry about is that you know
what if fortnight starts to fall off mmm
so so you're actually on King side which
is you think this is a very isolated
installation based on the dominance of
fortnight never salon that they need to
do it I think they just need to do it
this is where the industry is going they
need to do it okay they've proven that
they can do it you know they got such a
big head start over Microsoft and just
in terms of popularity and and market
share that it's whatever Microsoft is
doing as positive as it is it's a tough
go to climb for them so yeah they're
still winning without doing this stuff I
just think in terms of being and I said
it last week at some point when you're a
market leader you have to take the lead
on these big things you cannot allow the
two guys under you to keep making these
strides forwards and and then you're
like okay I'm gonna follow suit doesn't
look good it just doesn't look good at
some point you have to you have to be
the one that takes a charge and goes
forward so answer me I think they have
to do it but I do understand that
fortnight is a different beast right a
different beast and we have not seen a
game with this sort of penetration all
across
the board and the problem is is if it
falls off like anything like anything or
tonight as powerful as it is and as much
money as epic is bring it in
what if something else usurps it then
what happens later it's it's happening
it happens year after year sooner or
later something will right replace it I
don't know how long it's gonna be fun
now sooner or later like you know it
won't it's not like you'll completely
die because it won't but sooner or later
that we something that comes out they'll
be pop I mean pop G used to be that
thing right let me jump in because um
there's this I for thought these all
interesting rumor number one to me with
the name change that's happening you
know I'm saying and um just one thing
I've learned about Sony over the years
is they're very aggressive right they're
competitive and they also they want to
control media cycle like they want to
control the narrative and this week
that's me who's a strong Microsoft week
right it was you know for as a drive you
getting Excel news you know and I felt
it was a very shrewd move to kind of say
okay bold you know the name changes or
what have you so I think that's
happening on the back compare with the
rumor to man I'll be huge
they'll be huge because in my opinion
they got the games of the generation so
now you basically reassuring your base
this awesome library is coming with you
you know saying if they pull that off
that's a chess move and that's the thing
do you think that they would do
something like that because I feel like
especially of one of the reasons that
they have such good games might be a
reason not to do it because they know
what they make these remakes that they
know they make these you know these
words there's yes five people are going
to buy them because they had such Dom in
a game I think normally I would agree
with you the problem is I think that
what the what the cross play thing
showed me is let's be real day we're
getting dragged in the media fad State
for the first time really the June they
were not the darlings consistently all
the time yeah all the time that like we
were out there you know say remember
King like they it was you couldn't get
away from for at night news people Oh fu
Sony I can't raise my I was locked
my whole thing is with that negative
backlash again with the biggest game I
get it but I also realized that Marcus
office Nintendo jumped on the weakness
they were like look we play together you
don't
it was it was perfect timing to really
needle them at their weakness and let's
keep it a buck Microsoft's biggest card
is services one of their biggest card
this whole gin is back compact we've
been riding back up a shout shout out
the bill still on the team you know say
that is the greatest innovation they
have and they can link every time
because even Sony fans joke whenever
sony announces a new game right this is
Microsoft's game right whenever sony
announces a new game Microsoft PR will
tell you about all these new DJ Bari I
see his tweets always interesting you
know the here comes Mike itself with
these great you know classic backpack
games that people want to play so I
think they're both playing off the
in-suite picks that up you're saying
that's just me so again if they if they
already do it and it's rumored that the
PS 5 more more than likely starve is
gonna have that AMD architecture which
would be the same as the ps4 would you
make that transition easier cuz with the
ps3 it was different it was a sell so
maybe that's what I couldn't do it from
hallway but that the last one whoa 29th
replay PlayStation 2 games what do you
like if you look at it from a standpoint
that like the people were working for
Microsoft on the software's aspect like
they work magic yes because when they
were talking to your CEO and they asked
him there like you know what's your
response to tobacco is compatible like
you can look at that interview he seemed
like I don't know how they did it
I'm curious about oh but the machines is
gonna be so much alike and you can wish
it hope in my oh you like
my vitamin it's just my thing is will
they do it I feel like at this point
they have to put a lot I mean they're
clearly not giving up on now like so my
thing is I don't know what they're gonna
do with that sir 2019 again to me if
true Lama that would be very aggressive
in like I told y'all I Opie know PSX
they weren't there now very limited
predictable III showing that we all are
the Lord's one of us the roundtable was
like that's all y'all showing like
what's up with that so when I see that
kind of stuff to me is suggested cooking
up all coming Nick [ __ ] right well my
gut is I'm still holding on my 20/20 but
my gut now is saying they will
definitely announce it I think is
Microsoft that jumps out the window
first I think well we we said it that
that they needed to come out first right
but the question is are those games
gonna be ready right they can't come out
again touting the best third-party and
not to pivot off for the PlayStation
topic I know you PlayStation guys once
your topic to be you know isolated to
yourself but remember these dudes is
joined at the hip because when he moves
he moves but I
honestly feel that this is how the
dominoes will fall Nintendo has noticed
that a lot of these major third-party
games aren't on their system as much
growth as they shown from going from the
Wii U to the switch they would love to
extend that reach into the third party
realm all right because they have they
have fell back to old Nintendo where the
first party games is pushing the system
that third party games is lacking now
they're getting some games on it a third
party that's making us go wow I can't
believe that's on a switch you
understand but they want that to be more
commonplace instead of more more like
like a red herring Microsoft knows that
they can't let Sony come to the market
first right yeah I've been pushing these
two system thing one is a hard hard
waste and you have the that's a stream
system so they're trying to get you with
the the cheaper price and get you
because they already did this thing
right now if you didn't know it's $24
you can go get yourself Xbox one extra
money right now and be part of that or
pay every month plan now you've been
doing it with your cell phones and
everything why are you doing it there oh
they're ready for that I've noticed just
like y'all just said sony has scaled
back they mailed in III cut off while
the PlayStation X stream so what they
yeah so they go full steam ahead they
want to extend their Dominus and I'm
pretty sure that they got the memos like
your Microsoft was coming next year
Mikey borrows said these words and Phil
said these same exact words to me
verbatim
don't mix next year it's going to be
epic both of them said the same thing
mm-hmm no coming off of III that the
Dominus I don't care what y'all say
everybody can sit there say Gosa Sheila
go away with that the dominance of
Microsoft at e3 was evident they said
okay Sony said okay y'all won't play
that game I don't really think that
backup at stuff is not happening they're
gonna push the power of the system when
Microsoft might be hampered with the
fact that they're gonna tell you oh you
can play all your games
and we want everybody to come inside so
you'll give a hell about that we're
gonna show you the power from the rip if
you want to play them old games we got
this thing called PlayStation now you
can get into bushes and getting in it
get played at but all the games from the
rip is going to show the dominance of
the system yeah they can probably be
equally as powerful but Sony will not be
hamstrung by the old generation you just
alluded to my last point which was
basically the whole 2019 thing and I'm
with you on a lot of points King because
at the end of the day if they are to
drop in 2019 this is just my personal
pain I think that's a huge problem for
Microsoft because you can't allow them
first to the market you have to be the
same at them are thats just my opinion
based on town bastion ll be i gotta get
you in absolutely I'm not I'm not saying
that Microsoft's not um foreshadowing
what Sony's doing I think they learned a
valuable lesson about the power
narrative with the X they like a lot of
thing I'm with ul I just feel like they
have to I guess my concern with
Microsoft is this if they are forced to
come out in 2019 and is if Sony's ready
what would Microsoft launched with
that's my concern because we know
everything's cooking up right we know
the Infinity Gauntlet knows we got all
that comment you know I'm just worried I
like talk what would you think they
could come where I told me like what
what's your opinion if it is 2019 on a
Microsoft side um I think that they're
gonna come out with fable I think the
game was already in development so
they're not starting totally from
scratch so they're taking you got
playground games which we everyone knows
this is making this game so you figure
they have a full year to work on a game
now it's probably more than half
finished to make changes to pratik it
and polish it and get it out there
on the total on their factory mode right
now in factory mother right now that
they're trying to pump them out I think
that the normal cycle that we saw
they're probably trying to take games
that are already like that and then just
polish them slightly a compatibility
model which is kind of like could could
be upscale for the UM the next-gen
console to Scarlets must be right
because you know like most people don't
know the like like god ward it's so
different because God of War was not God
of War at first right it was a different
game and then they were like man we can
just make this out of war and it'll have
the clout of God of War so better so
many times people come up with video
games that are very similar to old games
and then they make those slight
adjustments and push them out even with
okay I just want to jump into checkers
check going in on us digital tiger said
King what dominates they showed no
relevant exposure mystic with Microsoft
has never won a generation all right all
right all right you you right now you
Conor McGregor and you whistling through
the graveyard right now this is what
you're doing you the great guard when he
was going crazy I told you a lot of
times that was fair and a man's heart I
hear you that's very your heart if
you're gonna tell me that you didn't see
that
III and you walked away from that III
with flute man you thought you winning
you I want you to understand you don't
know what dominance is then 43 I was
there you viewed it on your TV or on
your phone are but however you consumed
it I was there I consumed it there then
I saw the Sony show has said what is
going on but I also walked away from e3
and said game of the show was this
little guy I told you that but I told
you certain
up Microsoft told you we're coming and
we're carrying a big stick pause and the
ballade playing they're buying Studios
now those games that were coming they're
gonna they're gonna release that system
with the bacon egg and cheese the new
gear you'll get a new force again
because you just got horizon right now
so the new force a game is coming daddy
they actually said no for the next year
digital did you tag it says Sony
pullback to EP because Microsoft showed
nothing about multiplex but people don't
realize is the conference's are months
in advance they might do slight little
tweaks remember wha
we've had plenty of people on the show
that that go to these meetings and they
say that the smallest little thing is is
planned for months at a time and they
might change a little things but they
never changed the whole direction of the
conference itself because everything
that they're doing right now is for ps5
I want l-boogie defend herself from what
digitized fatal comment he just said
it's not what you do you think these
people own stock like me
one thing is like I said it's gonna be
interesting 2019 shot the sandwich at we
gotta definitely revisit this next year
to see how this thing plays out very
interesting boomers yelling sorry
no good saying I think EXO will be
telling ya EXO will learn a lot came out
with their own show that's that's
telling you know what I'm glad you said
that because this is where I'm gonna
listen I'm getting right now I'm getting
I'm get you right now right now you like
cuz you so what I gotta do is I gotta
introduce you so you sitting here
telling me today
there was no dominant it to me show
right i'ma show you something
dominus was so big that your peoples
canceled a show oh I think it's a good
chance that they launch next year to
come affable I think fables a twenty20
game and I think they're coming next
year with this game O'Leary Monde at
halo that's part of the reason that you
know kind of makes me think it's going
to be a twenty20 but you know I've had
conversations of a bunch of people like
this and of thing what is it it's gonna
be launched a night and next year it
might launch at the beginning of 2020
well I don't think income tax books I
don't know but at the end of the day
like I think it's gonna launch with Halo
and I think especially this new engine
the new direction like you know if halos
good enough that will be enough hmm
told you
this is no sleight to Nintendo they
launched the income-tax town where
people had these chicks somebody sat in
the marketing team and said where is
their money that we're not kidding
this is what was dead
income tax time they have excess money
they want to ball out brother
it's true and sure enough that switch
sold like hotcakes and I said you know
what it was it was the income tax
dollars they pushed him because I had my
boy told me yes lose like a man contacts
I'm getting that's with Oh Eureka
they found the goldmine March from
January to March is that time it's like
I said
halo 5 wasn't that game it wasn't like
you know it was this I would say well if
I was a system seller but it didn't live
up to its predecessors it was trash but
you know they weren't just system
sellers they defined the generation for
that whole console and if they can hit
that goal of mine with Halo 6 and you
know read generalize that that fan base
like you know Sony did with God of War
that will be more than enough to launch
a console with but don't I don't know
what they could do it that's the thing
we're gonna see this is like I said
we're gonna learn a lot I agree well
boogies like we don't learn a lot in the
next couple months but you learn a lot
with EXO we're gonna see what's going on
2019 we have got to move on we run in
crazy
[Music]
everybody playing father
[Music]
[Laughter]
now see ya instead you could get this
game in game past Microsoft said because
a lot of people in my party didn't know
that game paths will be getting first
party games from Microsoft more first
party games but when I said it uh
hardcore was like what because he was
talking about buying Forza I said his
in-game path right now he said your Lion
King I said I'm not lying all the first
party games you know that comes a
gamepad so he went he downloaded it now
when I say the game pass effect the game
pass effect is all these Sony because
they were playing the game spider-man
and then and he really thought they was
gonna get like some bare bones some old
crumbs and stick it's game validates
game pass big to be the fact that I'm
saying is now that this triple-a title
has launched in there because every
every game the launching game past they
have always said something or didn't
have enough content or it was there was
bruising it was they had to fix this
this game is solid all the way around
the boards mmm this is the first title
can stand on its own merits in the store
retail or in-game pass now the effect is
what does Sony do now and what does
these game pastor does it does this
subscription sheet do the wolf because
it is what is the effect of this game
launching in game past this real good
solid title what happens out real quick
because actually the most popular games
on game pass right now fours is one
rocket leads to see
these is three fallout 4 is 4 and
Wolfenstein is 5 followed by the Master
Chief collection enable 5mm or is it
just came out obviously it would be one
I'm kind of curious like seed these is
still three I think a lot of people
don't realize that games actually do
well on this service you know how I know
game past is doing something what's up I
was at my friend's house and she runs a
daycare and you know sit there and one
of her daycare mom comes in and she
brought her son's Xbox cuz he was gonna
play that and she was like well what do
I do with it she said oh no it's fine
just looking up he's got game fast I was
like wow cuz I didn't really think it
was doing like that and I was thinking
myself this thing's really sell like
that game download it fire zone and
shout out to people to catch that lady
well-read in for me to check it's good
to see you shout the game for it take
several that's what's up yeah like what
do you feel like like you feel like um
you know is this tremendous tremendous
value or like into King's point how do
you feel about Forza horizon in it
because like King said like prior to
this you know you had this day to decay
you had the sea of thieves and for
whatever you know for different issues
people had took issues with certain
aspects of those games so do you feel
like Forza horizon is like that first
legitimate feel game pass game like
triple a quality kind of fourth is the
epitome of what racing should be on a
console like so they have the best
metrics the best cars the best graphics
the best everything everyone had to bow
down and agree flak for saying oh my god
forces like actually having a review
like I do want to point out right in
from you did saying this service
Microsoft needed a service because their
games were not selling like in the past
yeah oh game pass is a great value to a
dot more I don't think it's because you
know whatever there
we're not so I think the reason game
pass exists is because EA access exists
I mean when they saw the kind of because
a lot of you don't you know don't
realize this Microsoft has access to all
the all the traffic that EA access yeah
when they saw those numbers they're like
they went to the drawing table like we
got to do something bad dot this today
I'm gonna give you something a little
bit deeper and I had this little
epiphany the other night when I was just
sitting there by myself and is it that
Microsoft because you know they have
these spies their network is very vast
same thing with Sony I don't ever
discredit these companies we're doing
their due diligence on what the
competition is doing and we all know
from sovereign its speaking us into
existence that these streaming systems
from Amazon and from Google are actually
at the precipice of being launched right
so you said that these systems is on the
horizon and Microsoft said okay we know
that they're coming there's nothing that
we can do to stop these news from coming
through this door but what can we do to
secure when this wave hits because you
know that Amazon will be a pretty my
dream in we go set up these traps to
ambush really like you know Google will
be streaming how can we set up a system
that has all our games encompassed in it
and we can already build a base because
Showtime and HBO would have build the
base before Netflix and who got in here
you understand they wouldn't got over
running in a manner that they're getting
overrun so I do you do you think that
that game pass is a pre-emptive move to
not just Sony but to Google it's all of
that because I think what the primary
lesson that Microsoft has learned since
2013 is that you cannot pigeonhole
people into telling them what they want
you have to give people choice and so
what they realize is ok how do we get
back how do we get back market share how
do we get people to like us again well
we give them the platform that offers
them the most amount of choice as to how
they consume their games and that's what
they do
so it's pre-emptive all across the board
because it has an answer to everything
right they have their own streaming
thing coming right and and they have to
be ready for that because Amazon and
Google Google has the largest reach of
any of these companies you know the Nick
they're talking about giving you
Assassin's Creed Odyssey in Chrome in
your browser that's insane like you
Microsoft doesn't have that type of
reach right so they have to give you a
number of different options of how you
engage with your games and you pick
what's best for you and um when it comes
to the game pass effect with with Forza
I think what Forza does is that it gives
you a it does it just finally give you
that Triple A game in that space that
says wow I'm paying $10 and this game is
not short on content if the way it's
built it's an online game it's basically
destiny with cars that's what it is
that's that's a horizon forest so that
you're coming back to it and now like
imagine imagine when the new console
launches and you could tell somebody you
know what buy the console is gonna be
$400 $400 and here's six months a game
pass and in that six months you get our
entire first party launch lineup you
don't have to pay anything else for Halo
Gears or whatever else is coming down
the pipeline anything is that's how they
get people you give P someone three
people don't like change if they had
that for three to six months for free
they you know they got ro into the sea
thieves whatever is gonna be on a halo
once those are up they're going to
subscribe like and the thing is it not
even subscribe like the subscriptions go
up but you see that the sales actually
go up because like I said what choice
what they do alright for the horizons
in-game pass right but if you want to
get that four or five days early here's
this you got the hardcore Halo fans
they're not gonna wait for game PES
they're going to get that four day early
bad and now only are they gonna get that
they could have spent more money because
they're spending eighty two hundred
dollars to get that game early and I
didn't think I was that kind of person
then Halo Wars 2 came out you will do it
for your game hi
we dread if we go to the chat hard right
bad guy I gotta say some stuff so first
of all she made some comments she was
like forces one game against also
Nintendo online uncle five years that's
so bad and she made some comments in
reference to Microsoft being you know
Xbox being taken seriously as a entity
in the Microsoft you know ecosystem the
point I would say to that is which I was
kinda explained in the chat which is
that like this is different in a sense
that one this is the first time Meyerson
who didn't view Xbox in that light is
not in the picture anymore he's a lot of
responsibility for that as well as we
all know dawn you know they bring his
name up but um now that Phil is actually
at the table and pointed by such that's
a huge culture shift you know saying
have you've seen it with the acquisition
of his studios and stuff I'm not
disagreeing with you as far as what
they've done this Djinn and how many
great games I'm with you or that which
all I'm saying is you there's definitely
a culture changing as far as the the
game path specifically all one say is
that I do agree without booking a sister
this is the first in my opinion like
super high quality not much flaws that
I'm like wow I just really got this game
low-key that for free but it feels
lightweight right because normally you
know what there was a finesse right I
felt like I was finishing because I'm
witchy King like when that first week
dropped in you know all the early
adopters get to get it early and I'm
looking at my game pass at like y'all
was somewhere Xbox needs talent also and
they've been doing that they've got I
understand that argument because again
they haven't they need the games need to
be there period and new games need to be
there does it can't be just halo gears
and studio make another game that's
unheard of they're letting make another
another game they engineer
it's looking like there's going there's
a lot of rumors that they're buying an
obsidian like they are making the these
progressions to fix what needs to be
fixed they're not understanding
all right Microsoft is the same building
complex right that was run and let's say
that the pipes weren't getting done and
the stairs weren't getting done and the
hallways weren't being cleaned and the
elevators were shoddy and then new
management came in new management came
and kept the same building and said oh
this is a dope building all you gotta do
is just fix up these things alright so
the people that believed in the project
decided to work so now they had to go
out and purchase the contractors to do
the work contracting work don't get done
in one day they went and purchased
studios those games will take time all
right
so you will see that this building will
look better
these Dell evaders will run finer the
hallways will be cleaner the steam will
work I'm giving it to you in a layman's
term so you can understand games are not
made yesterday they don't acquire a
studio and that studio comes in to porch
the game over and say you got game all
right takes time Sony didn't build this
overnight I was there Ground Zero when
Sony showed up to the party and they
didn't have game initially that it was a
lot even they were getting beat in the
head by Sega and Nintendo and when me
and you were sitting in sovereign was
sitting there we like know the Saudis
dudes is all right and these studios
were a joke they were a laughingstock
and they built it took time to build
don't act like Microsoft and Sony came
into the party at the same time no Sonny
had a pedigree before Microsoft
Microsoft is the neophyte here all right
you gotta understand Microsoft is the
neophyte Microsoft is learning that 360
thing that they
did to the big brother they push big
brother in the mouth that's the first
time you noticed that little brother can
wrestle right brother punch big brother
in the mouth
oh this at the end of the day Microsoft
is doing exactly what people wanted
they're taken their you taken the gaming
approach like they take every other
drawn or they every other industry they
try to get in to throw money at it
mm-hmm they wasn't doing that for the
longest time because I I look he do
think that Microsoft you know remember
the rumors that they were trying to find
someone to buy X the brand Xbox I think
that was that was lowkey happening but I
think Phil Spencer presented it in a way
to keep it or because at the end of the
day though Spencer doesn't have to he
doesn't have an anarchy that he goes up
anymore he just gotta convince it to the
people he said that that side would
that's all you don't go through Myers
said my recent gotta go through whoever
he was a boss with he gotta go through
he is right there where they discuss
where the money guy but here's the thing
he's the big point and shout to the Lord
Santo BER who just hit me he's making a
great point I think we're all missing is
that as much as people say what they
want about gamepads we have to admit
from a financial standpoint it's been a
success you don't saying both sea of
thieves and state of the cable on the
NPD and from what we're hearing right
now from this article from game industry
got buzz it's already confirmed that
Forza horizon 4 is already hit number
three sales fought in Europe the Middle
East and Australia and that's why our
September 30th so and this is no game
pass numbers so at the end of the day
that is generating the growth that's
generating the sell the service is
working whether you feel there's quality
games or you know overall how you feel -
often to generation that's one thing but
we cannot understate the success of this
service for them and Forza horizon is in
theory their crowning jewel on the
server nasty we can't lose track switch
out at the same Tober
hit me with that as that's fantastic
news I didn't even realize he was doing
that or these people are coming from I'm
getting tired to say you know we had the
way cuz in all since we've been saying
that for four years
oh absolutely at the end of the day like
I got a PlayStation and a switch like I
don't
sitting around on xbox all day most
people have multiple platforms I you
know what I really I play a lot of my
multi plants it's my destiny machine
that's all this thing right and I
enjoyed for that because I have my
friends on Xbox like one place they
should drop something
I played spider-man for two days
straight people be acting like people
have to like it's like it's like they
have a life contract and they have to
write it with blood most people are
broke their purchase preach it I've
always said I feel a lot of this console
war stuff to be completely honest you
just know that it comes down to
financial responsibility and they go to
this which one should I get
and you make that singular choice now
when you make that singular choice yeah
yeah you gotta justify you're lying in
bed rocking rolling it not all of the
gamers are like US Airways like if
something's good on another platform no
we got it okay
some people like nah but I already you
know spent this money in this ecosystem
and it game sucks and you know it's this
whole thing to just a single platform
purchase and I completely agree with you
and what's funny is that all these
people that I see critiquing Xbox they
don't even have an xbox like literally
people will go on there on go on
Metacritic score the pop up you know
stated okay I will say see these isn't
for me I'm not gonna call the trash it's
not for me but the pop up stated okay
see the 69 demon trash and not even try
any of that I'm just like look at the
end of the day stated okay might not be
for you but a lot of people take
Metacritic they take a this console war
thing way way too far it's like if you
if you go on Twitter
shoutout to Kratos the
it's trash it's like everyone that like
that they right there with them it's
like you know how I know it's bad when I
can't say I didn't like the boss fights
in spider-man and I get destroyed on
Twitter like I can't even make her cheat
when I play it when most of these people
that have caught it on this tweet
haven't even played the game I can't
make a critique because I'm an ex boss
it's like dude I played more protecting
me it's viewed as hating at it you know
nowadays when you have an opinion and
it's not in line with the majority is
viewed as hating is viewed as your salty
is viewed as something else other than
you just having an opinion on something
that doesn't job your way like you know
if you don't like something or you or
have critique about something it's fine
everything every aspect Xbox
it's like equivalent of me attacking PS
now it's like oh they're you they let
you download the ps4 ps2 games why not
the ps3 games like like it's like game
pads like why can't we just say it's a
good service why do we always have to
find the little things to anchor it down
why can't we go okay that's a good move
on Microsoft why is it always have to be
so they can so they can publish trash
the grass it always have to because they
can't sell games why does it always have
to be because they have meteor games
that don't worry it said they blows my
mind when a game like Forza horizon
comes out I'll give you stately decay
and see these had low Metacritic scores
that has nothing to do with what was put
on game pads that is a review aspect for
multiple people in the industry averaged
together
that's nothing to do first off I love ya
you know
I'm not I'm not in my fault right now no
when you was talking about that
PlayStation then I have nothing at
Ground Zero against Sega take a [ __ ]
up at e3 alone in Atlanta with Sega
standard first off what PlayStation came
out had a nice lunch
so from PlayStation boy rebuttal when
you can't became weak yet Syphon Filter
Ridge Racer white pal Metal Gear Solid
OH PlayStation what we're gonna do is
we'll get into that because being that
you wanted to ambush me I want you to
see what this shirt look like now I want
you to understand you understand what's
really happening right here are you
gonna guess the mouth no no no what I do
is I'm a
I didn't want you to take it out of
context when I told you that Sony was
the neophyte going up against those two
big jug knives all right we talked about
the missteps of Sega we know this we're
not saying anything where we're staying
is this and I told you if you listen to
the context of what I said was Sony
Studios were not up to par you just
talked to me about third-party titles
right you just talk to me about rich
race and rich race that was made by
Namco
right what what what I'm explaining to
you is at that point in time Sega and
Nintendo had a giant pedigree
they're giant pedigree you couldn't put
nothing in Tendo came on so he came up
with against a Mario you understand but
now he has that can actually hang you
know Sony actually has titles that can
actually stand the test of time God of
War and these games actually show that
they have built studios that could
fortify against any attacks coming their
way but in the beginning it was not so
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question cuz I'm gonna make it either
worse for you because the fact that you
came out with the whole first part in
this first party dad
name one generation that Microsoft ever
beat Sony globally worldwide ever so my
thing is out the gate out the gate no
I'm going I'm going through it out the
gate Tony of never loss now let's go to
Sega name one generation did singer ever
[Laughter]
you showed up to a fight to my dish
Sony Playstation one came out it came
out in 1994 and Japan in 95 and 95 in
America right 1999 to be exact right
with Saudi King because PlayStation 1
vs. Sega said let me Sonic the Hedgehog
there's a Drago none of these games
commence with what PlayStation came up
with the game because their first year
in a business deals that demands to make
these games was only on PlayStation so
for the moment it shows a platform what
you're telling me is this is what you
get the combat King
I want you to be honest and I want you
to stop it right now I want you to be
those those Studios when they came out
was they as strong as those same studios
now today that's the conversation what
you trying to turn it into is the Sony
show great that's fantastic
what I'm explaining to you is in the
beginning when they were getting their
footing and they were learning the ropes
their studios grew to a pedigree that
they can stand on they oh that is
something that you can not deny that is
something that you cannot walk away from
that is something that is a fact
let's do this
the first big exclusive now listen to me
listen to me
the first biggest Busan that came from
like a so nice to do that ended up on
PlayStation was pilaf in addition
digital's Gran Turismo Turismo right
right when there is no came out it was
labeled as the best racing game party
there so my point is what you're trying
to say correct me if I'm wrong what
you're trying to say is you're focusing
solely on Sony Studios games that they
me are you there yeah when it was
building the infrastructure so nothing
is so much things to you when Sony came
out with their games they set it off
with Gran Turismo then then Naughty Dog
came along and that was Crash Bandicoot
so if you want to talk about Sony in
their Studios the things that they was
doing during the first era of
PlayStation right is what led them to
the victory here so out the gate if you
want some about out the gay rights Tony
was coming out with hits dead set them
up during a place that should one ever
gave them the victory over 64 and Sega
Saturn that led into the ps2 which led
into the players away in the studios
when they launched they had a pedigree
and they was that strong yes over time
yes
over time I'm just asking you a
yes-or-no question yes people go into
the grocery store
alright saw a parent going to the store
you're a parent let's say your parent
going to the store and you know Nintendo
and these new boots show up and they
have crash bandicoot and they have Mario
as your parent understanding that this
established franchise is there your son
has both systems right is in reference
to the whole marks of studios and whole
game pass thing you know with the
generation and she made some points and
all we always just talking about cuz you
made some good points in reference to
you know them not having the great games
initially and that Microsoft wasn't
really taking Xbox series and all the
point I'm trying to say which is in
reference to the whole statue in the
template Ella and
bringing filled to the table and a lot
of those decisions were Terry Myerson a
lot of those decisions were done so it's
like for us to expect that we know
they're getting killed in the gin and
it's far as the quality gate it's not
even a comparison we know this but
weight loss they that was going on now
with the game passing have a quality
exclusive like a four zone that's pretty
what nothing I'm saying which I was
saying was wrong what I was saying it
was is that the need for like someone
has said well Nintendo and wisest pony a
Nintendo doing anything of that nature
and I was saying well there Baxter's not
against the wall gosh
you don't need to come up with some type
of solution or situation in order to
stay relevant they care about you no
game pass but EA access why is Sony
making all the ps4 PS - I mean parently
they do feel some kind of heat from that
service because that was a decision that
was already and put in place okay so
then how do you alright so that's a good
point but how do you explain then them
also acquiescing on cross play which is
something they had a sports there's
first of all last June Sony wanted to do
cross play what Microsoft and Nintendo
systems are you talking about that we
are talking about now but in order to
know about now you need to know about
what happened from before talking about
the fantasy right yeah Final Fantasy and
other games as well that they wanted to
do as multi play people's given in flack
now and as far as Sony doing it now
they're coming to a place well okay if
the fans wanted the Nate then why not
reason why they did not want to do it at
first it's probably because of some
bitterness and also because of a
business standpoint as far as a model if
I was to buy something on Microsoft and
Nintendo and yet or if I bought it first
on Sony yet I'm using those same things
on the other ones now how am I actually
making money off it at one game if I
have a partnership with that one title
right well understood
point as far as the courts play from
before it's so funny how Microsoft is
wanted to team up with Nintendo
to say hey why did you cross play and
we're for the gamers last generation
when they was on top they didn't want to
do me shows we already dictated they're
coming from the back position pose that
you're actually both of your archive of
last shows he's asking me a question now
about he's asking me on why I'm saying
what I'm saying so I'm answering or what
I'm saying and why so I only can answer
what is being asked but other than that
that's that's what I'm talking about as
far as the the position that Microsoft
is in I'm glad that they at least trying
to do something to stay relevant stay up
to par as far as the talent um that they
are clearing that alley is not enough
that they have some talent that they got
right now is playground and Ninja Theory
right now that can make something happen
right as far as the other games and and
the thing the problem on what Microsoft
is going through and like every e3 every
e3 I go to I'm always looking forward to
Microsoft before all the other to when
the reason why is because I'm looking
for them to actually shake it up again I
already know what Sony's gonna do I
already know where Nintendo is gonna do
cuz they're consistent I want myself to
be consistent what they're gonna give
the gamers are they want to be favorable
again to the gamers that's why they're
doing this stuff that they're doing now
than any others like this is the third
of course but they've been very
inconsistent with their marketing what
they're trying to do at least Nintendo
have redeemed themselves from Wii U with
the switch right let you know exactly
where they [ __ ] the bed and what they
want to get better at right we have a
really faint light as far as where
Microsoft we stain it with a game pass
an Xbox with service right with services
that's not till concrete on wait the
Xbox one X power I want to see the full
power not from a third party I want to
show me the true power and why I should
complete buying a piece B to play at
titles just real quick just after that I
gotta get not one Bob we got to get
l-boogie after mm-hmm
God you saw like one of the things is if
your marketing campaign is about being
the most powerful system and you got X
plus one X out there but ya got a war
know when you go help with you guys
based on past I LPS we've said
everything you guys are saying like
please like we we are in agree yeah my
favorite Xbox okay because y'all look
very informative
I'm not crazy with it I don't come
because if I'm gonna turn into an Xbox
podcast I'm gonna hear mostly about Xbox
and how y'all feel about Xbox and so far
of course you're gonna talk about
PlayStation Nintendo cuz of course is an
industry to go in line with and you know
I got my brother I love when podcasters
with the platform that they're most
passionate about have some actual ethos
on what they're talking about so I do
employ y'all with that and everybody
that's on the panel even right now so
what y'all hold podcast all right I love
y'all podcast love what y'all doing -
let me get out boogie cuz she's chomping
at the bit I don't think that it's a
all flaw that Xbox is per se
quote-unquote with their backs against
the wall because competition breeds
innovation and Xbox constantly comes
with the innovation like yes like even
back in 2013 place was happy RM day that
is true that is true they did delay the
coffee try the sweet sweet shut up wipe
the [ __ ] up and say oh yeah this is how
you share game this is which was
brilliant marketing I was doing it yeah
I was gonna do the same thing right
and really it was the idiots that didn't
know where technology was going because
there is like a minut amount of people
that know where technology is and know
where technology is going to know that
DRM was a necessity is the next step
because digital all digital is the next
step like we weren't ready for it games
are like was it halo right it's like a
hundred gigabytes step there that's huge
well this car you putting that on what
disc is allowing you to put that on
there and PlayStation doesn't even have
a blu-ray player
so what disc are you putting that on
yeah I resolved games in the 4k and all
that stuff listen about an innovation
one thing I could say about Microsoft in
the Xbox brand is when they introduced
the hard drive in a console and Xbox
long yeah and the to point to where you
can actually have your system link
straight through your team may say that
is cool but that thing also allowed you
to instantaneously shift back and forth
through your home system your TV your
network and it took an account of what
was going on
people they see the viability but
Microsoft did yeah I feel that
but see his nothing it was an innovation
I feel everybody played a part in what
we see into dancers innovation so for
example so for example um if if
PlayStation hold a PlayStation 2 did it
bring DVD in painting culture overall to
the mainstream and yes it was the first
one who do all um Xbox didn't in the way
where it like really really worked I
mean was able to build off of that but
Satan did do it so but it was innovation
Nintendo Sony and Microsoft all had so
um it turns to me I do protestant mall
cuz they did they all get great it's my
slide the hard drive in there Sony with
the DVD now one thing I wanna talk about
when you look at the place they should
now in the game pass like I just feel
like they both doing the same thing but
backwards as Buster's about to come out
with their streaming service PlayStation
did their streaming service first now
you won't be R to download the
PlayStation stuff and play it natively
and spice did that already like so I
feel like they throw the same things but
just did it in Reverse so that's that
right there is good too I love it now
now all the reasons like the bottom line
is for me the reason why I had to jump
for this part can tell me why you jump
it that's what I love here's the thing
that made me jump in now now when when
you made the comment about um you know
like slowly being trash no like you
can't space odious trash out the gate
when
Sega and Nintendo took Elle's when Sony
came out the game and it was way before
the Kings got complacent
the Kings got complacent they sat there
only throws and they got
so he came in with the hungry belly and
everybody go you okay oh yo you know
what you know what one day I'm gonna
just come to your crib son and we don't
do this but yeah like to me the bottom
line is this the reason why you buy a
game system at the core is because of
the games and for Sony it's a beast
Nintendo speak not risky but honey for
Sony to come with a new you never had a
console ever to come in and beat
Nintendo and Sega out the gate and it
wasn't just third party games it was a
mixture of third-party games it was a
dance coasters and it was a mixture of
business deals right that was it that
was the triple cuz from a business deal
standpoint my fancy 7 was the genius
business deal oh that's one second
support Wii games like Crash Bandicoot
sent its own to the point where you got
crash bandicoot coming on Nintendo's yo
Crash Bandicoot they made a commercial
we crashed going to the Nintendo office
I remember that stuff that was done by
seed listen you're talking about a dude
that sat there and watch these other
teams fight you don't ever forget about
sega does what nintendon't you know that
stuff but stuff like that they saw
market and they understand what the
people wanted Sony was nationally for
the people at that point in time now do
we understand that they're getting fat
now
you know it is decisions like you know
Sony may with the Final Fantasy seven
that really you know they've always been
good on the business side because let's
be like I don't even want to know what
cause Final Fantasy seven along with
other games they really help that
PlayStation brand get really big imagine
if you say what I'm saying I love you I
got you just I'm just saying like there
was one more thing I want to say to the
trifecta that I had and that's trifecta
is games that stoney me like games by
Syphon Filter at that time all games
like Gran Turismo then they came up with
the wipeout like these like games like
twisted metal that wasn't consistent
with keeping those second and third
party titles on their platform all right
we got a little bit off-track by sitting
here with the sony fanboys I do
appreciate is the fact that you did Bend
an inning now there's the fact that they
built they they they pedigree from early
stock
I got one day family cuz hip-hop member
had you on and at that time 17 the
switch had launched and me and solve was
coming for you because you said that
let's see a 20-18 switch was coming
through the switch was doing wait
ps2 numbers was doing know that this
switched because of his name because of
the same pattern that the ps2 did and
which was on par with it I already knew
what this was gonna be in 2018 and I had
told him that but you listen wait wait
the reason why I did want to wait is
because you gotta see the year-over-year
where they were because it's already map
piscatella for NPD who we had on this
show has already projected them to sell
the most in 2018 from a revenue
standpoint so do I need to wait for them
official numbers to come back we get the
knee bending is very important because a
lot of times out the gate and that's for
anything people could get like real
height because of the moment so
standpoint you have to really analyze
what's really happening and what it did
those numbers from here 1 then CMAs
which do the same thing I'm like go to
switch is gonna be crazy by 2018 yeah
yes which is crazy but my thing is like
I said yeah any coming out with they do
anything Oh what I'm saying is like I
like to see from year over year right
and see what it is
because that's the way you can measure
the behavior of the consumer you can
feel somebody one day then next year you
ain't feeling them
you got to see how they go all day first
of all thank you so much for coming
through and just like I got read I gotta
get you on for sure I loved you to chat
you absolutely really appreciate what
you're doing I think yeah I mean I
appreciate y'all for what y'all doing
always love to give you know support if
y'all need help with anything just let
me know and I know you move over there
that that space over there from the
other space to the next place um I do
appreciate everything that you're doing
I told you that a hundred percent you
know Sam and I met do I think it'll be
real cool I gotta figure I want to do it
but one of these days I want to do like
a I in law's podcast live except
everyone's in New York
I escaped you anal you have to fly it
but uh but my thing is um I think it'll
be really cool because I New York I got
the space to do it like we can probably
do it at vaynermedia which is again
Gary's space and he has the twitch and
everything set up so we could probably
like go live strangers like for example
I got
no to include you know like you're in
debt because the awareness would be huge
like that that's one thing yeah talk
about it but I really think that I'm
really good cuz I have a great podcast I
got great chemistry and you can tell I
come from a real place of love when
y'all like talking with one another
doesn't feel awkward luckily I
appreciate you I love y'all ready y'all
continue doing your thing
but yes I'm you know that was much
appreciated
all that was done we got the hottest
[Laughter]
just great to see I'm just gonna go
solve them and talk you do not have to
dead the last two if it's cool cuz we um
I'm just gonna announce the power switch
2.0 and you know obviously they're
talking about a possible revision and um
you know basically what I feel about it
and you know so basically you know what
we know is just that it may include the
hallway improvements and more efficient
at battery thinner device high quality
LCD screen you know so apparently it is
definitely coming our Wall Street
Journal in 2019 and um and also solve
you were talking about let's combine our
top you were talking about Rocksteady
game right yeah real quick on the switch
thing I don't think I think those are
the improvements we getting I don't
think it's gonna be a more powerful
machine I don't intend oh doesn't care
about what we want I think it's gonna be
a more efficient machine smaller maybe
better screen all that stuff but
probably yeah they probably improved the
dock in some way shape or form
um and in terms of the Rocksteady stuff
so there was a rumor that came out of
Reddit and resetter ax which then got
sort of published by PlayStation
lifestyles where I saw it
um so basically the rumor is that
Rocksteady's next game is actually
another game in the arkham verse
as opposed to rumor Justice League game
or maybe a Superman title there was even
some jokes this past week when the
footage of that Harry Potter game came
out that that might be their game and it
turns out it's not it's probably
Avalanche software's game you guys used
to work out this infinity so the rumor
is it yeah that it's there's gonna be a
new Arkham game coming from Rocksteady
just I want to know what you guys feel
about that because to be honest I love
Arkham Asylum
I like the improvements that they made
in Arkham City I was a little
disappointed Arkham Knight um I wasn't
fan of the tank stuff it just felt like
it wasn't enough of a leap um and from
what I'm seeing as bullet points of what
could again this is also rumor and
speculation the bullet points of what
the improvements to this game are and -
it doesn't feel to me that it's enough
um when you see we've got Lucy game like
Spider Man out there when you see Red
Dead coming down the pipeline when you
see what Assassin's Creed is doing
there's a bit there's been a
redefinition of an open-world action
game um so let me go real quick with the
bullet points on what this is what this
game is so supposed to be coming out
2019 isn't coming out it's targeting
this gen in terms of consoles um it's
going to be in the ER it's basically um
all of Gotham City so as opposed to kind
of more closed in environments with
Arkham City Arkham Asylum in software
you didn't have civilians around
apparently submit the city will be
bustling so you would do side content
like you would like in a spider-man game
you know like robberies and stuff like
that which is something that they hadn't
done before they only focused on you
know Batman and the bat family sort of
messing with like goons and stuff like
that right um so the world is supposed
to be living and breathing you're
supposed to be able to play as multiple
members of the bat family um as opposed
to just Batman is supposed to be co-op
gameplay um
which they didn't detail what they're
gonna be doing with that apparently the
UM the villains in the game will be the
court of owls if you don't know the
court of owls they were introduced
during the the new 52
they're basically a loom
knotti type like organization it sort of
holds power in Gotham City um so that
that would be an interesting story to
take and basically they the bullet
points also include stuff that people
were not happy with with the last game
basically Batmobiles is gonna be
transportation only um every character
can be using free roam the Batcave is
gonna be sort of your center for like
upgrades and all stuff like that
um and the big thing is gonna be the
multiplayer oh you able to play and
co-op oh you'll be able to do co-op
takedown moves co-op stealth stuff so um
I won't know what you guys feel about
this if this is something that you want
would you have preferred them to do
something else in the DC Universe and is
this enough considering like the games
that I mentioned before and the
improvements they made to the open-world
formula is that enough all right I'll
boogie I need you to double question so
switch revision 2.0 and this Batman new
game supposedly are you interested
series switch 2.0 emulating your games
you know literally that's like the
reason there's no real upgrade this is
people are gonna buy it I'm sure
King what your feeling on it oh the
switch I'm hoping that they do the Tegra
2 chip inside the machine or hope they
feel dark little or put something else
in there
I my thing is the lack of third-party
support in the top-tier titles I know
that y'all might say okay the 2k
basketball and they got important titles
I'm not saying that the titles that they
did get aren't important they're
important to the ecosystem of Nintendo
but what I want to see is a broader
spectrum when it comes to these
third-party titles to be included into
the switch as well mom with that being
said
I'm still gonna play on my playstation
and my xbox certain titles now off to
the Batman um I think we're gonna catch
fatigue on it I think this is gonna be
the lackluster title I think this is
gonna be the title to make sense which
from the company because um you're
beating Batman like a dead horse um do
something else
so let me see some daytime action
because everything is that nighttime is
it did they say anything about the day
solve or just say anything about a
day/night cycle they just did say that
it would be a living world so it's not
you know like you know the story wise
and all the Arkham games they had a
reason for why there were no civilians
there right mom so they're trying to
make it a true open world where you can
do you know so what addicts favorite
stuff to do you know around doing
meaningless tasks and collecting old
batarangs supposed to be their true last
game in the back pointa by time I wanted
something different you know jump in
real quick obviously you know I was
surprised by the news to hear about it
so um yeah I mean listen I'm all for it
to give them a shot to see what they do
to see their new take on this game you
know obviously it's a beloved series you
know and if they corrected things I know
a lot of people had issue with the whole
Batmobile inclusion and how that was
handled so I'm cool well now you got me
when you said co-op what type of
cooplets the key how is it implemented
is it true cop co-op is on you know I
gotta see that I heard the characters
the back family will be in it Nightwing
which I'm interested in the Catman all
that Red Hood sounds great it's just a
matter of implementation and shot up
take a man I like what a Warner Brothers
is doing with that Harry Potter that got
leaked so if they're going that route
you know graphically and all that you
know I'm with it but you know for what
my topic with the switch 2.0 obviously
you know I'm very interested in this
news so on I'm winking with you King
like I mean my gut I'm actually what
l-boogie my gut says it's gonna be a
small revision gonna no beings like
screen nothing a little bit better
battery life you know and probably won't
be a true regeneration reflex like the X
or Pro but I
or small a median because he said um you
know the actually intended would broke
Presidents before and I don't even
realize this because with the 3d s Excel
they had at greedy-ass
Excel only titles that would the new
Nintendo 3ds the one that they added
that the 3s Excel was just a bigger yeah
version of the 3ds the 3d the new
Nintendo 3ds is the one that added the
extra horsepower exactly
so that actually surprised me and we
know grandpa beat to his own drum but I
thought you know like I was I thought
that's kind of ballsy to do even
something like that to leave kind of the
passion right that's a huge platform for
them you know so if they were to do
something like that I think with ballsy
my gut says they do not but um I would
love to see a customized version of the
Tegra 2 you know I mean and then it you
know similar there Fekkai like don't
have uh some bluetooth and damnit put
that on the system put their voice chat
app in the system that's all I demand I
don't even care this not even a revision
if it's the seams which put something to
it to give it that ability to do these
things I know y'all keep saying that it
has the ability to do these things I
think it hampers something when those
those things are enabled yeah I would
think I wouldn't think of you have it
running on the system something slowing
down that's for sure yeah shout the
chief tommy better screen battery won't
be able to hack it with a pay-per-click
power cable no it did break precedence
with the with the with the new 3dsxl and
making that and they were necessarily
successful with that there were only two
games which was a dieter dynasty dynasty
warriors zelda game and the say no play
game that was it so if they they usually
don't do power revisions in the first
revision of something right
so I just I'm not confident with the
recent rumors but the ps5 launching in
2019 and having ps4 and possibly having
ps4 backward compatibility
how important is the timing of the
release date for the Xbox scarlett
console the choices are a Xbox should
only release call it when quality games
are ready be if ps5 releases first there
is no chance Xbox can make it realistic
comeback see Xbox much must match ps5
release or launch first or D I don't
care no one wants that smoke with the
switch Pro in 2019
that is those tomorrow lady L thank you
so much for coming through and dropping
them at knowledge where can I find
people find you what you got going on
you can find me on twitter @ l Baguio
208 mixer LBO 208 my schedule will
probably be changing soon so please stay
tuned also I'll be streaming later on
tonight with an extra code of a month of
game pass ok who's trying to get honor
that ports a train that's what self make
sure you come through check my Twitter
and I'll let you know when I'm bout to
go live no doubt much appreciate and
thank you all the work that you do with
the stream team that out the small door
so we could let them know what you're we
had like two topics like you guys must
have skipped them no we to hip hop in a
lady read in for me for coming through
what's your ILP stream team schedule is
that's the Wednesday we'll be doing we
do Tuesdays at 10:00 that might change
though Tuesdays at 10:00 exactly and
we've got me we've already talked
offline we've got some things cooking up
for the stream team and like I said
please tuna support she's out here she's
a true game she really represents the
culture and we're very proud of what
she's doing so again salute l-boogie
no doubt and of course Lord addict
dipping on us and then coming back at
the end wake in the family on Twitter I
OPA
Lord addict I hope you can find me on
youtube the gaming addict I will be
streaming sinner sacrifice redemption on
the IOP channel I think I got my
streaming stuff fixed I don't know yet
both crisscross and you know that should
probably happen to the next week I'll
have to look at the embargo code for it
when I actually get the because they
they send all that to you when they send
you the email I don't know what the
embargo code is yet but I'll definitely
be streaming that and I'm gonna be
posting a lot of content on that
particular game well it's gonna take for
king to play that on the IOP Chen no
doubt laws solve IP the patron die bank
what is going on we're gonna find
bluefin
first big shout out to l-boogie for
coming through and dealing with our
foolishness
okay marathon very elephants and shout
out to our patrons as always thank you
so much for the support you guys can
catch me on Twitter Lord saw ILP and BX
sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live and I'll
be playing some Forza some Assassin's
Creed later on to date online I'll be
online later on today you guys you know
I'm a fraud on you right now because I
told you that morning that you're
supposed to be on you didn't show up so
we know this
but I must say it is a pleasure having
you on the show when we started stream
team and we started submitting names use
the first name that I submitted all
right and he was my number one pick you
was my eighth pick and I'm so happy that
it did work how it is working and I know
exactly you're gonna do great things
so with that said I want y'all guys to
get over to the IOP store buns at T
Springs I want you to hit that link I
want you to then I want you to get that
jay-z green if you have every color when
you're it's gonna get put up I'm sorry I
preempted and do apologize but that
color is coming we have also other other
lines that's coming um budget-wise and
green what I want y'all to do is I'm one
shot to after y'all get out of here and
y'all on YouTube I want you to go to the
IOP channel I want you to subscribe like
and subscribe put a comment down on any
video that you see up there because that
is the only place that you will catch
flashpoints that is the only place that
you will catch a combat talk with the
kings and you can catch IOP there as
well
i need you to go there to subscribe
because the subscribers is not equaling
out to what we have as followers alright
so and in doing that when we reach a
thousand we need to reach that thousand
when we reach a thousand the benefit for
you guys alright and that's what we're
trying to do so I think we're at 400 and
some change probably 500 and it's
supposed to be higher um I every time I
do talk about you guys you guys are
extended family like Jay Fonzarelli
native these guy I know these guys they
are family right so and I'm happy when
he wins a t-shirt or when he wins a game
I want to give away systems all right
absolutely looking on that absolute
means a lot to us again we're trying to
do positive things in the community
trying to stay away from the negativity
as you see is always love we joke we get
at each other but it's all from a place
of love and again it's Louisa Lou
like I said hip hop and Rec Remy for
coming through because they felt
passionate enough but they wanted to
cover it and love something in my Jack
ring you know you know sometimes I
really even if it's a differing opinion
on a subject I love that to come in
state your case show us why you feel the
way you feel that's the type of
engagement you know we don't always have
to agree but it's all good that we don't
agree and we long as we respect each
other this whole place because one thing
we love this gaming thing that's what
it's about
so salute set them for coming through
the royal couple we already know the T
Springs is up with the shirts more
swagger be coming this is the first line
already know that Chi boxers gonna do
audio also big another special
announcement we are on Google Play and
Spotify so for all our Lord's watch on
Spotify you have no idea how hard it is
to get on that surface yeah just to
prove us they said just wait a couple
days it's going down and of course I
King said the combat talk is Leahy he
predicted it gonna watch him you know
saying combat totally can't predicted
the broad I could have told you to Kobe
was gonna jump out that ring right now I
would not be in New York I would be
somewhere a little because I bet money
my brethren I bought is salute he's just
being best friend on YouTube he's by
selected by YouTube please support him
for his whisper of the worm's solo run
that is my brother's my look at my bro
man I
love working with them we have a good
show on IOP check us out that's usually
fried thank you so much lb I see I'll
begin a chat we really try to bring
destiny for the Harcourt appearance and
that's it we went over but thank you
guys for Rocky and if anybody's got
anything else we're good
alright everybody enjoy a Sunday please
[Music]